e
it being 2:00 we will open the public
hearing on house bills one and House
Bill
two we the members of the house finance
committee are gathered here today to
listen to the public as we are analyzing
the governor's proposed budget for
fiscal years 2026 and
2027 we must fit it to the revenue
proposed by the house Ways and Means
Committee that Revenue differs from the
governor's estimate by almost $800
million
in an almost $16 billion budget
obviously this is a bigger challenge
than most
budgets but less than some previous
challenges we also have the fact that
the current budget is on a path to
overspend by about 50 million we have
new legislation passed by the house this
session of 1.6 billion we will deal with
all this by a close examination of all
departments so as to efficiency and
employee
vacancies we may update fees that have
not been increased for decades we do not
have any proposals for new taxes as of
yet typically 30 to 32% of our budget is
from federal spunding federal funding
scattered throughout most departments we
do not at this time expect big changes
in established grants there was a lot of
concern regarding the future of Medicaid
we have reason to think the federal
changes are likely to sustain funding to
the state along with more
flexibility the governor has proposed
specific changes to the state
Administration that will protect
patients while calibrating spending to
the while recalibrating spending the
subcommittee of our committee is
evaluating the governor's process I will
remind you that in the previous budget
we made a substantial increase in
Medicaid due to the high inflation rate
just prior to that budget now I've given
you a lot of information in the speech
and still did it in less than three
minutes this is the time limit we admire
in this chamber so we must restrict all
your speeches to that time limit so that
more of you can speak I have over a
hundred requests I also request that you
avoid duplicative remarks if several of
you are speaking on the same topic
please shorten your remarks to something
like I am also speaking on whatever the
topic was I agree with the previous
speaker and have nothing to add or if
there was some brief thing that differs
from the previous person that would be a
good time to add it so that is what we
here for here's the house finance
committee and we are ready to listen to
your testimony we will first call on
Andrew Haron go to either of these speak
these microphones phones there in the in
the back thank you all for being here
and please as I said keep your remarks
said Mr Harmon microphone right in front
of
you got it yep thank you um my name is
Andrew Harmon oh um is this
on my name is Andrew than two inches of
your mouth oh like that that's pretty
good
okay okay
my name is Andrew Harmon and I'm a
resident of new Hampton New Hampshire um
I also have the pleasure to serve on the
regional coordinating Council for
Community Transportation in my region um
which is belnap parts of Hillsboro and
Marat counties though I'm speaking on
behalf of myself today and um I wanted
to ask that you please um look at adding
back in the um money that was taken out
for supporting transportation for the
banum
of uh 6.8 million uh I also wanted to
speak to the Medicaid that you mentioned
um I work as an independent contractor
and my income is very fluctuating but I
tend to fall into that Granite St the
granite advantage of um 100% plus
poverty um by a little bit and this 5%
increase would be an income tax I'd have
to pay and I would not be sure exactly
what amount I would be paying paying
since my income literally changes from
month to month I've had some months
where I've made as little as 200 I've
had some months where I've made almost
1,000 and so not knowing how much I'd
have to set aside would be a huge
problem uh especially since some of my
medical needs are not always covered by
my Medicaid thank you very much and um I
wish you luck with all the testimony
[Applause]
well next call on
Glenn it looks like cab
loock
6727 is Glenn
here oh okay might want to read the next
name and after him I'll be calling on
Verna sharp so you a vimma sharp you
might want to get ready if it's going to
take a while all right Glen
welcome thank you very much before I do
that I'm just going to hand out these um
uh test testimony to the Committee
pronunciation yes thank
you how is the last name pronounced knob
loock knob loock that's knob block like
door knob door lock okay my name is Glen
noblock I'm here today from wolfboro uh
with my daughter Anna noblock who's
right beside me here um not present is
my wife Terry who could not make it
today um and we're coming here to
testify in support of HBS one and two um
just a little background Anna is 28
years old has been availing herself of I
guess what we call Northern Human
Services uh since birth since the day
she came home uh from the hospital
Intensive Care Unit at Dartmouth and our
family really relies on these services
and so we're very concerned to see uh
that they continue to be funded and also
there needs to be a mechanism in there
for inflationary concerns especially
when it comes to paying for inhome
supports uh and support people that help
us inside our home um Anna uh has
benefited from these Services her entire
life it is very hard when you're in her
condition she has a neurological
condition by the way she understands
everything that's going on here today
she can see here everybody she just
can't speak for herself I might also
mention she's a registered voter so if
there's anybody here from the Carol
County de delegation keep that in mind
um um uh so early on we've relied on
these services to purchase things like
wheelchair ramps U modifi modifications
uh so she can get in a wheelchair van uh
simple tasks that many of us take for
granted I used to take for granted are
very difficult for Anna getting around
so the socialization aspect from these
funds is really important also just the
fact that paying inh home support is
getting more difficult especially in The
Lakes region where uh jobs are um trying
to hire people is very difficult and
trying to pay a living wage to folks
that come into our house to help care
for Anna so we can have vital respit
time uh and mental health break if you
will for my wife and I uh because when
we don't have that support it's her and
I my wife and I
247 so these funds uh not only need to
be uh continued but uh find some way to
pay these caregivers uh a decent wage
it's a shame that uh folks that work for
us my daughter is medically involved uh
nobody can even work with her until
they've had a month's worth of training
and uh they're paid uh less than
McDonald's employees no offense against
McDonald's employees so um so I asked
for the committee's uh uh thorough
examination of this and you know the
granite state has a wonderful tradition
of supporting people like my daughter we
want that to continue thank you three
sharp honorable members of the house
finance committee thank you for this
opportunity my name is Verna sharp and I
am a New Hampshire native um I'm here to
speak on behalf of my 33-year-old
disabled daughter who is in the hospital
right now so I appreciate uh the bump
thank you very much um she is a New
Hampshire resident and she um would be
severely impacted by any cuts to
Medicaid she is uh in a day program uh
through Community Partners uh in area 9
and she also lives with a skilled home
provider uh who is her caregiver and
receives a a good a decent salary for
the very hard work that she
does Medicaid is such an important
program and it's more than just
Healthcare it funds the services that we
receive through Community Partners in
area 9 and I was here in 2011 to urge uh
the folks to uh fully fund the weight
list uh back in 2011 because Alyssa was
uh aging out of the school district what
were we going to do um if she didn't
have a day program to go to I would have
had to quit my job I had a mortgage to
pay I would have had lost my home in
foreclosure and then what if I can't
make a living and Alyssa is not uh in a
Day program out in the socialization
piece from the last speaker very very
important um you know where would we be
um so if we can all agree that we all
deserve health care right but we're
worried about the financial aspect of it
I would ask you to consider the velocity
of money if you pay a shop owner $100
for a good in their shop that $100 that
shop owner takes and maybe pays somebody
else for a $100 service that $100
service is going to be paying for that
person's mortgage their taxes whatever
um you know expenses they have the money
keeps going that's the economy and I
want you to know that Medicaid money it
doesn't just disappear in a vacuum it
isn't just this Giants amounts of money
that just goes you know that's spent on
something that's not worthwhile it helps
keep the economy
going it funds the salaries of the
people that provide the services for
Alyssa's Day program and her skilled Pro
home providers and if those funds are
cut I'll be back where I was in 2011
having to quit my job in danger of
losing my home and just staying home
with Alysa not knowing if her health
care and her needs will be
met thank
you next we'll invite representative
Mark uh Mark vone to speak and that will
be followed by Megan sergant
representative
alone there was some note about he had
to he had to be done and leave maybe
he's already left all right is Megan
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Evans doe I'm the director of
operations I apologize about
time um good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Evans doe I'm the
director of operations um of Team select
home care we are a Home Care Agency that
provides private dut nursing and home
health aid for medically fragile
patients I'm here today to strongly
oppose the proposed 3% Medicaid budget
cut while this cut may seem like a cost
saving measure it has ultimately lead to
far greater expenses serious
consequences for vulnerable patients who
rely on home care services if this cut
goes into effect home care agencies such
like ours will struggle to attend I'm
sorry to afford nurses and caregivers
necessary to provide critical care for
our patients these patients many of whom
are children with complex medical needs
will be left without medical support
they're
required sorry to remain stable at home
without proper Home Care these
individuals are at much higher risk of
hospital visits which are sign sign
sorry sign much more cost to the current
Medicaid um much more cost than the
Medicaid reimbursement
um rates we only need to look back at a
covid-19 p pandemic to see what happens
when Hospital emmissions are surge
Medicaid bore the financial burden of
those emissions and without adequate
Home Care F funding we could see a
repeat of those crisis of this crisis on
the positive Aid the increase on
Medicaid funding we've re we received
has made remarkable impact thanks to the
investment of um of our agency to our
agency team select was able to hire 102
more additional caregivers
this allowed to improve our caregiver
retention rate by
87.3% a critical factor in ensuring
continuity of care as a result we've
been able to provide an additional 4,000
weekly care hours that's over 28,000
hours of annual care most importantly
this investment kept 168 Patients Out of
the hospitals with many of them
graduating from our program no longer
requiring medical coverage this success
isn't just about saving money it's about
improving lives and giving families
Peace of Mind I'd like to share a story
of one of our patients who is currently
not here at the moment but I'm use the
initials as Li a 15-month old boy who
depends on gtube trick and vent Li U
spent his first two months and a half of
his life in a niku but thanks to the
care we've been able to provide at home
he hasn't had a single Hospital
admissions since we began suppor since
we've been providing care for them this
was us this has saved Medicaid thousands
of dollars and that just one child
imagine savings when you consider the
thousands of patients in similar
situation cutting Medicaid's budget by
3% won't save money it will increase
hospital emmissions and drive costs even
much higher continue investment in home
care is crucial not just to control
expenses but to provide the quality Care
our most valuable patients deserve I
urge you to reject har thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so to give you some warning I
will next call on
Michelle schena
here here she
would you um yeah that's good hi senate
finan
[Music]
r
money to
in the group home I currently re
signed and um
in my new
hampsher um uh Easter
Seals and and
manages the house
and sorry and once SK owns the property
I
also um use
those
pun
to
maintain my
health and
wellness um and enjoy
um my out into the community I'm very
inventur um I also own my own arm
business um so I am a
taxpayer and I'm vo
um I think I cover most of
it um and thank you very much for
you next we'll call on Jane asley
sorry I'm a little choked up after that
um my name is Jane Ashley I'm
representing myself and my father and
very a lot of my friends um the cost
Effectiveness in healthc
care um really is
it's terrible we have a rotten system we
need to fix it we shouldn't be um taking
money away from Medicaid we should be
putting money into Medicaid I don't know
what some of the friends or people that
I've worked with would do without the
assistance of
Medicaid it's very valuable
but really I can't I can't say enough
about what will break a lot of people's
hearts make people suffer by reducing
the budget
so I guess that's it thank
[Music]
Campo good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Brian will president of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire Mr chair
without objection uh we have four
members that would like to speak um and
we'll we'll take very brief amount of
your time and then we'll move on you
won't hear from us the rest of the
day today I come before you alongside
representatives from other key Public
Safety sectors including Municipal
police officers State Police Corrections
and parole officers together along with
the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire which is the organization that
I represent we represent New Hampshire's
unified commitment to the Safety and
Security of the citizens and visitors of
our great state we thank you for
allowing us to speak to you today as a
coalition of dedicated Public Safety
professionals who strongly support the
inclusion of the group two retirement
Provisions in House Bill 2 in 2011 the
New Hampshire legislature enacted
significant reforms to the state's
retirement system aimed at improving the
state's Financial stability while the
intent was to strengthen the system
these reforms introduced sweet sweeping
changes to the benefit structure for
employees already in service changes
that fundamentally altered the terms
under which they had been hired and the
benefits that they were promised the
impact of these changes has been
profound and far-reaching creating an
unintended ripple effect throughout
Public Safety in New Hampshire many of
those affected commonly referred to as
the tier B group have expressed deep
concern and frustration as they
witnessed their retirement benefits
which they had worked hard to earn being
Stripped Away
this has led many to seek employment in
neighboring states or to leave their
profession entirely this Exodus
threatens to undermine the Integrity of
Public Safety in our state leaving the
rest of us to pick up the
pieces given that word of mouth is the
most powerful form of advertising
reinstating these benefits for those who
had them taken away should be seen as
the most effective strategy for
retaining senior leadership and
attracting The Leaders of Tomorrow it
sends a strong unmistakable message that
the state upholds its integrity and
keeps its promises the reality that we
face today is undeniable New Hampshire
is struggling to retain some of our most
highly trained and experienced leaders
and it has been widely acknowledged that
many who have left the profession have
done so because of the Midstream changes
to their benefits this is not merely an
issue of policy it is a matter of equity
and fairness for those who have
dedicated their lives to protecting
their communities we are deeply
appreciative of governor aot for making
this issue a priority in her budget the
retirement Provisions included in hb2
are a critical step towards preventing
the continued loss of some of our most
qualified and committed leaders more
importantly they fulfill the promise
made to those who serve and protect the
citizens of our state and if you just
allow me to wrap up Mr chair we also
wish to express our gratitude to this
committee and to the House of
Representatives for their overwhelming
support of these very same Provisions in
the 2023 budget which passed with strong
bipartisan support 282 votes to 80 this
demonstrates the broad recognition of
the importance of restoring these
benefits not only for Public Safety
professionals but for the safety and
well-being of New Hampshire residents we
are confident that the members of this
committee will continue to uphold their
commment to Public Safety and we'll pass
these Provisions once again thank you
thank
[Applause]
you Frank Campo followed by John
selli good afternoon my name is Frank
Campo and I'm representing the New
Hampshire Troopers Association I'm here
to speak in support of the group two
middle tier retirement provision that
was presented in the the governor's
budget this provision is very similar to
the bill that the house overwhelmingly
passed two years ago it offers no new
benefits it simply restores benefits
that were unfairly taken away from First
Responders prior to those changes New
Hampshire never had an issue retaining
police officers since then especially in
the past five or six years Police
Service in the state has become a
revolving door those pension changes
that took effect 13 years ago have
changed the culture and police work
being a police officer in New Hampshire
is no longer you're considered a career
it's considered more of a job it simply
isn't worth spending a whole career in
police work in New Hampshire I have
worked for the State Police for 20 years
and in the past 10 15 years I have seen
scores of well-qualified and talented
men and women leave the state police for
other law enforcement agencies in other
states um as well as the federal
government that offer much better
retirement benefits uh it's time to
change the culture back to how it was
the citizens of New Hampshire want their
public safety personnel to view their
service as a career not just a job those
middle tier members that had their
benefits stripped 13 years ago are now
the senior personnel and the leaders in
police and fire departments across the
state the time is now to restore the
benefits that were taken from them so
these leaders can in good faith begin to
change the culture back to how it was
thank
you thank
[Music]
you next is John selli followed by SAU
razi
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is John selli I'm here
today representing the New Hampshire
Police Association I'm also a sergeant
with the Nashville Police Department I'm
here to urge the house finance committee
to support house bill to in particularly
the restoring of benefits to the group
two middle
tier what we've recognized since these
changes is police and fire departments
across the state are struggling to
retain their qualified people with much
of the workforce coming from our
neighboring states we have to stay
competitive with our retirement we are
currently not and more so we have fallen
behind
significantly for example in Nash
Massachusetts has has been our number
one competitor and resource for
employees the Nashville Police
Department currently has 164 active
police officers with more than 20
openings 107 of those 164 are from
Massachusetts that's 64% of our police
department since
2011 the nille police department has
lost 69 officers to resignation that's
officers that resigned prior to reaching
their retirement
benefits of those 69 27 of them left to
go to Massachusetts law enforcement all
citing that the retirement issues in the
greater benefit in Massachusetts is the
reason for
leaving each officer who leaves it costs
the city of Nashville over $100,000 to
replace that officer in approximately 12
months of training to get them up and
running before they're considered part
of the uh staff to go out there and
protect the uh the
community that's a great cost to the
city and this is a sweeping uh problem
for each and every Community within the
state so again I urge the committee to
support the restoration of the group two
middle tier retirement so we can provide
the retirement benefits that our
dedicated First Responders deserve and
help ensure we keep our trained police
officers here in our communities and
firefighters in our communities to
protect and serve here thank you for
your time and consideration thank you
[Music]
next we'll listen to seu razi good
afternoon Mr chair Mr chairman my name
is sa orasa I'm a chief provision par
officer of the State of New Hampshire
I'm also the president of the New
Hampshire group to retirement Coalition
the Coalition uh is currently
representing firemen police officers
corrections officer provis par officer
and nurses what we characterize and
Define as First Responders we are here
before you to express our support to the
government to the governor's initiative
about supporting the group two members
that have been affected by the change
back in
2012 um obviously there are the people
we depend on in bad times and during any
difficult times in the state during
covid you all have learned and have seen
when everyone is depending on First
Responders First Responders every day
showed up to their work to protect the
people of New Hampshire Ur residents of
New Hampshire safety and Ure at the cost
of their own safety and risk since that
change in 2012 we have become a
recruitment Depot for other state
surrounding area no State and I repeat
no state had taken a benefit promised at
the time of employment 9 and a half
years after the promises were made but
the state of New Hampshire remained to
be the only state in the United States
that affected uh First Responders and
this Governor had acknowledged as a
former AG this Governor understand the
need to maintain Public Safety the need
to ensure that we provide a quality of
life to all of us in the state of New
Hampshire and if she had put something
in that budget we would appreciate your
support your committee support to leave
because we like to remain as the number
one state in this region which maintains
Safety and Security to the resident of
the state and any assistance you could
give this Governor to restore and keep
our trained person and retain them we
the group two Coalition member about
1,800 members of the Coalition will be
supportive because at the end of the day
unlike ha State we're not asking for any
kind of pension sing we're just simply
asking the promise that was taken and
fairly N9 and a half years later so we
we we respectfully ask the committee
will support that the governor's
initiative to establish a durable
solution to this problem and thank you
thank
[Applause]
you next we'll call on Executive
councelor Karen leot Hill will be
Pritchard thank you very much good
afternoon members of the finance
committee my name is Karen Leo Hill and
I have the honor of serving as the
executive counselor for district 2 we
need to make life easier for granite
Staters not harder and when the state
fails to cover its obligations life gets
harder for local property taxpayers when
the state faces a difficult budget
environment and cuts spending local
property taxes go up when the state
reduced its retirement contributions for
teachers police and firefighters from
35% to zero in order to balance its
budget local property taxes went up to
cover the difference by hundreds of
millions of dollars contributing to the
high taxes many of us pay today when the
state fails to provide cities and towns
with their share of rooms and meals
Revenue local property taxes go up when
the state fails to cover special
education costs and diverts taxpayer
dollars from public schools to private
schools local property taxes go up
and when the state
fails thank you but don't cut into my
time and when the state fails to fund an
adequate education for all New Hampshire
students local property taxes go up I
know this because I've seen it firstand
for the past 20 years as a city
councelor New Hampshire property
taxpayers cannot afford to give handouts
to wealthy private institutions through
Universal vouchers and lowincome Granite
Staters cannot afford to subsidize the
state budget through Medicaid premiums
please pass a state budget that meets
the state's constitutional obligation to
fund an adequate education for all
Granite Staters and does not simply
shift costs down to local property
next will be Maggie Pritchard followed
by Mary wil all right hi there I'm
Maggie Pritchard I represent the New
Hampshire Community Behavior Health
Association and I'm currently the leader
of Lakes Region mental health in
Plymouth and in lonia I want to thank
you for the opportunity to address you
today and I want to call your attention
to the ongoing needs of the mental
health system in New Hampshire we've
made some significant progress but more
work needs to be done we're happy that
the governor has called for an
investment in mental health but we want
to make sure you understand what our
priorities are and our priorities really
center around uncompensated care housing
Medicaid rates and community behavioral
health clinics so for uncompensated Care
Mental Health Centers eat if you will
giving services to people who medically
need the services that we provide but we
can't collect from private insurance and
others on we also have to deal with
people who have Medicaid who are on
what's called in- andout um that's a
very popular program not with me or
anybody else that I know of but it is a
deductible for people who are poor who
can't afford to make those payments and
in order to get their medication and
other services we the Community Mental
Health Centers eat those cost the
Medicaid rates we are calling for an
increase in Medicaid rates that's
sustainable and ongoing because as you
know our Workforce is dwindling and we
can't attract people who we can't pay
wages that they can live on we also know
that the state of New Hampshire has
invested a lot of money in what's called
community behavioral health clinics
those are a
transformational change to mental health
in New Hampshire where you have One-Stop
shopping and you treat the whole person
so you have medical services and Mental
Health Services allinone um the state
has made a significant investment but
it's going to take take the legislature
to keep it up because it was funded on
grants and has proven to be successful
we have three Mental Health Centers
right now West Central naswa and
Manchester operating clinics so I thank
afternoon thank you next will be Mary
wilky followed by Tim
Diaz thank you I'm Mary Wilkey I'm a
property taxpayer from conquer and I
urge you to take any money you might
consider allocating for Universal
vouchers and direct it instead to our
Public Schools uh proponents of vouchers
will often tell stories of children who
have found something lacking in their
Public School saying we need to
prioritize what's best for each
individual student but their focus is
always on the child who wants to leave
the public school and never on those who
remain take two High School classmates
Josie and Marie both love art but their
school can't afford to provide art
classes their Public School the best way
to address their individual needs would
be to fund the district well enough that
it can provide art which would benefit
them and many others but what happens if
instead we rely on a voucher program
Josie's parents take a voucher and send
her to a private school with art classes
and her needs are met but Marie's
parents don't have that choice because
maybe they can't afford the difference
between the voucher and the tuition of
the school maybe they can't provide
transportation
maybe Marie has a learning disability
and needs special ed services that
private schools usually do not offer or
maybe no private school will admit Marie
because she has a bad report card or
disciplinary issues so how exactly do
Universal vouchers prioritize Marie's
needs over time as more money is
diverted from Marie's school to pay for
vouchers her opportunities will diminish
maybe World Language your lab science
classes will be cut or class sizes
increased and this in turn will make
vouchers more attractive to those who
can use them diverting even more money
away from Marie's school this cycle will
ultimately lead to two parallel systems
of educating educating the public a
separate and unequal system that meets
the needs of students like Josie and
leaves those like Marie with less
opportunity with every passing Year from
its beginning the whole premise of
public education has been to offer
opportunity to every child regardless of
income or any other Factor and the way
to do that is to fully fund our public
schools which are open and accessible to
everyone thank
you next Tim Diaz please restrict your
remarks to three minutes that will be
follow thank you that will be followed
by uh Joanne
Wilhelm good afternoon
my name is Tim Diaz and I am the
executive director of Meals on Wheels of
Rockingham County I also serve as
chairman of Meals on Wheels New
Hampshire a group which represents all
of the Meals on Wheels agencies in the
state at occasions such as this our
agencies provide nutritious meals safety
checks and precious human interaction to
older adults in our state in congregate
settings such as senior centers and
often sometimes in local restaurants as
well as hom delivered meals on behalf of
the over 20,000 citizens of the state
whom we serve I'd like to thank you for
your past support and to ask you to
revisit the prioritized needs submitted
by DHHS which proposes a modest increase
to the reimbursement rate we receive for
the nearly 1.8 million meals we serve
each year it is our understanding that
this new rate was derived from a recent
DHHS study of the cost agencies like our
ours pay for the services we
provide your support of this request
would help ensure the financial
stability and indeed sometimes survival
of agencies like ours and that means we
can continue to serve our clients in the
face of riseing cost means we can feed
them chat with them make sure they're
okay and call a loved one or Protective
Services if we're
concerned I hope I don't have to tell
you that to the extent our service helps
people age in place at their home doing
so is much less expensive for everyone
involved than an unnecessary move to
assisted living or even a nursing home
and that move very often comes after a
911 call due to a fall which can
sometimes be prevented by catching a
safety issue at someone's home what you
might not have heard though because you
are literally buried in budget numbers I
understand is that something like 30% of
our home delivery clients Statewide tell
us that their driver is the only person
they see every
week every
week beond beyond that many report that
the meals we deliver to them are their
only source of nutrition in a given week
so in terms of being the eyes and ears
of the community on behalf of a citizen
sometimes were it and make no
mistake our clients are the people that
served most of us in one way or another
when we were younger moms dads Aunts
Uncles veterans First Responders den
mothers baseball coaches local business
owners
teachers I guess I wouldn't be doing
this job but I wouldn't be here if I
didn't believe that we now have an
obligation to serve them in a
sustainable way that they should be able
to trust us to look out for them the way
we once trusted them to look after us I
hope you agree so I thank you for your
support and your service to the state
thank
[Applause]
you Joanne Wilhelm will be followed by
Ellen
farum thank you Mr chairman and members
of the finance committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify today my name
is Joanne Wilhelm and I'm here to
express my strong opposition opposition
to hb1 and
hb2 doing away with the interest and
dividends taxed last year has created a
budget problem in our state but cutting
essential services for our most
vulnerable citizens is no solution and
it's devastating to the way of life here
in New Hampshire the governor's proposed
budget makes deep and harmful cuts to
Medicaid affordable child care and
Housing Services that thousands of
granite sters rely on these Cuts will
directly harm lowincome families seniors
and people with disabilities leaving
them without the support they need to
survive and
thrive at the same time this budget
allocates millions of taxpayer dollars
to fund private school
vouchers primarily benefiting wealthy
families who can already afford private
education whose children were already
attending private schools and are now
receiving a significant cash bonus I
want to remind this committee that the
education Freedom account program was
passed by being tucked away in the state
budget several years ago do not allow
this kind of lack of transparency to
happen again this is an irresponsible
use of public funds diverting resources
away from the public schools and
services that the vast majority of our
residents depend
on furthermore by reducing State funding
for critical programs this budget shifts
the financial burden onto our towns
forcing them to raise local taxes just
to maintain current service levels this
approach is neither Fair nor
sustainable I urge you to reject hb1 and
hb2 and instead support a budget that
prioritizes the needs of all of our
residents particularly those who are
most vulnerable and cannot be here today
to speak for
themselves our state must invest in
strong Public Services not take them
consideration next will be Ellen farum
followed by Rob
NATO hi thank you for giving me this
opportunity to speak my name is Ellen
farum and I live in Tamworth a small
rural town with high property taxes we
have an aging population with many
people living on fixed incomes and we
are struggling right now to fund Our
Town services and our Public Schools I
there find therefore find it astonishing
that this proposed budget adds to our
problems by including money for
educational Freedom accounts
I oppose efas as they would drive up our
already high property taxes and largely
benefit wealthy
families my grandchildren two of whom
have
disabilities attend public schools where
they receive a solid education and the
services that had helped them grow and
Thrive efas will not only cost our state
more money but will undermine the public
schools that have served my family so
well this budget also hurts our most
vulnerable families by underfunding
important programs that have already
been mentioned here including Medicaid
and Housing Programs our we need the
child care and a Workforce we need to
attract a child for we need child care
and to attract a Workforce into our area
and to provide opportunities for our
young people to live and work in our
state this pill bill will drive property
taxes up and harm families I
Carney good afternoon thank you for
having me today my name is Rob NATO I'm
a former educator and a member of the
Hopkinson School Board and our board
representative to the Hopkinson Town
budget committee I'm here to encourage
you to support the caveats of House Bill
550 and 603 regarding adequacy and 734
which I Now understand in heading back
to committee the first two bills
regarding adequacy in my view are simple
open and shut cases of fact base
adequacy as illustrated by the conal
case currently comes nowhere close to
meeting the financial realities of
providing an adequate education for our
students for a school board special
education costs are the most difficult
to forecast and most crippling to our
budget process for instance in this
calendar year we are upside down a half
a million dollars based solely on two
unforeseen out placements so yes I
believe the base adequacy differentiated
aid for special education as well as
pration must be increase in this
budget however I would like to refocus
the discussion onto the equitable
distribution of the tax burden Hopkinson
just completed its 5-year revaluation in
that process the magic number of 78%
determined whether or not your taxes
would rise or fall personally my
property went to 83% my effective
property tax rate as determined by a
percentage of my income is 10% more than
fair in my mind
however I was curious about the folks
where it was perhaps less more than fair
so looking at the valuations I wanted to
see the percentages that increased
between 150 and
500% that means their taxes were going
to
double what I found most striking was 62
of the 127 properties that fell into
that category were in The Meadows a
quiet lovely mobile home park in
Hopkinson where most of its residents
are older some sometimes single often
times un fixed incomes and their
property taxes have doubled which is why
I would also support the intentions of
HB
734 the income property tax relief
program to offset that as spoken earlier
by the executive
Council when you increase adequacy you
help lower the burden for the people
that are least able to pay that property
tax that I believe is a duty that we all
hold as public agents I sit on a school
board as you sit here it's very very
difficult work I understand that but we
are still in the strangle hold of this
archaic property tax system so if we
could work together to balance that out
to try and make things better for all of
our citizens for our students through
adequacy funding and through mechanisms
for elderly exemptions and the property
tax relief programs as they exist thank
you for your time
[Applause]
[Music]
Larry Carrie from
bosan did I pronounce it
right is it kany it's Lori Cary Lori
you former co-sponsor of mine on bills
she
was followed by that will be followed by
chairman wer and members of the house
finance committee my name is Lori KY and
I'm here today as a former legislator
small business owner longtime School
Board member and a current select board
member I served 18 years on a public
school board seven years on a charter
school board and two terms in the New
Hampshire legislature these experiences
have made one thing clear New
Hampshire's education funding system is
failing our students and and our
taxpayers that's why I along with 241
local elected officials from 88 towns
and 67 school districts have signed on
to the letter before you today these
signatories represent
9,738 students over 57% of New
Hampshire's Public School population
this is not just a handful of voices it
is a broad bipartisan Coalition of
school board members select boards Town
count councils budget committees and
nine of New Hampshire's 13 Mayors in my
own District I recently spent eight
hours over two days in discussions at
the local school district meeting annual
meeting only to see $2 million cut from
our public schools because the state
does not adequately fund special
education and even though our local
budget in my own town has increased by
just a modest
1.7% it remains to heavy a burden on
property taxes especially elderly
residents and young
families this is the reality in
communities across New Hampshire the
state is pushing School costs onto local
taxpayers and forcing districts to make
impossible choices no Community should
have to choose between cutting essential
programs and increasing taxes on those
who can least afford it the letter
before you is a clear and urgent call
for Action the state must step up to
fulfill its constitutional obligation to
fund public education fully our students
and our communities cannot afford
another budget that ignores this crisis
you Liz Cody will be followed by Casey
Neil hello my name is Liz Cody and I am
honored to serve as the school board
chair for the city of Franklin I am also
proud to have signed the local elected
leaders school funding letter along with
241 other elected officials representing
67 school districts and 88 individual
towns as the smallest city in the state
we possess a strong sense of community
and pride and have made great strides
over the years Franklin has remarkable
students St achieving extraordinary
things in our schools and communities
and our city and school board work
tirelessly with our teachers
superintendent administrators and
community members to provide students
with enhanced opportunities but the fact
of the matter is our children are being
let down by the state which provides
only
36.4% of the city's total cost of public
education this inadequate state aid and
its impacts are compounded by the fact
that we are a community both
disproportion Ely and negatively
affected due to our relatively low
property values in short the city of
Franklin its students and its taxpayers
are harmed by New Hampshire's school
funding model and we are not alone as
evidenced by the over 80 communities
represented in the local elected leaders
school funding letter I'm here today to
support that letter and to let you all
know that anything less than enforcement
of the state court prescribed definition
of fair and adequate funding is a
willful attempt to undermine the public
schools especially in communities like
Franklin until they no longer exist and
our students deserve better than that in
Franklin in particular we have been
creative we have been Innovative we have
been agile we have forged Partnerships
and built agreements and relationships
with other institutions and groups to
try to get students what they need and I
say need because as we learned with HB
283 students need and deserve a
well-rounded education and yet as a
reward for our diligent work in
optimizing efficiencies we receive less
funding and are compelled to make
additional cuts that adversely affect
our students teachers schools district
and Community we operate with reduced
resources in Staffing and we must rely
annually on inconsistent and variable
grant funding to supplement the general
fund these struggles are perpetuated and
exacerbated by inadequate state aid
funding change is imperative you can do
better and you must for the sake of our
deer good afternoon I'm Casey Neil with
the New Hampshire school funding
fairness project I am reading a piece of
testimony on behalf of Regan lampier
from the national board of education
ation New Hampshire sends less money to
its Public Schools than any other state
in the nation we are dead last it's not
just unacceptable it's embarrassing a
budget is a reflection of your values
you spend money on what's important to
you right now 241 local elected
officials from 88 towns and 67 school
districts have signed on to a letter
before you these are Mayors school board
members Town counselors and budget
committee members including nine of New
Hampshire's 13 Mayors um and two of the
testimonies that I handed to you are um
pieces of written testimony from uh the
mayor of Berlin and the mayor of
Claremont um these leaders are
responsible for making impossible
financial decisions because of
inadequate State funding together these
local leaders represent over 990,000
students that's almost 60% of all public
school students in New Hampshire more
than half the children in our state
depend on the decisions being made in
this room in my own District I've
spent hours in school budget meetings
only to see $2 million cut made because
the state is failing to fund special
education adequately even with the
modest 1.7% budget increase the burden
on local taxpayers especially seniors
and young families is too great this is
the reality in communities across the
state I've served 18 years on public
school boards seven years on a charter
school board and two terms in the
legislature I have now seen how hard
communities fight to support their
schools but local efforts are not enough
when the state refuses to do its part
what does it say about our values when
year after year the state fails to meet
its constitutional obligation to fund to
fund education fairly we are tired of
waiting it's time for New Hampshire to
stop forcing towns to bear this burden
alone fund our school's property
properly follow the Constitution thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
shien good afternoon chairman Wier and
house finance committee members my name
is Michaela Deiter I'm speaking today on
behalf of the do school board who are
all signers on the school funding letter
you are about to
receive with over 3,400 students do has
the 10th largest student population in
the state we spent nearly $3,000 less
per pupil than the state average putting
us 17th out of 161 districts in Dover
like in every Community our board works
diligently to make spending decisions
that balance the needs of our students
with the financial realities of our
taxpayers as you well know the task is
not an easy one because New Hampshire
does not pay its fair share of the cost
of public education contributing a worst
in the nation
19.9% of of school expenses our local
taxpayers are forced to compensate in
unsustainable ways do schools spend 133%
less than the average New Hampshire
District we struggle annually to meet
the needs of our students and our
taxpayers still feel overburdened the
governor's proposed budget corrects a
yearlong underfunding of special
education Aid bringing it level with the
reimbursements currently submitted this
year but special education Aid
reimbursement requests continue to climb
year over-year the do school board
advocates for additional funding for
special education Aid beyond what
governor aot has
suggested in the past 10 years the
number of do students placed out of
District increased from 40 to 61 that's
a 52% jump in 10 years despite the fact
that our total student population
decreased by 10% during the same time
those 61 students received more than 7.4
million
of services last year that's an average
of more than
$121,000 per student per year out of
District placements are projected to
increase by four to 5% each year you can
see that on the back of what I handed to
you I gave you graph so you can see that
we're doing our due
diligence conservative estimates
indicate the cost will be more than
$200,000 per student per year by the
year
2034 that over School Board urges you to
increase both adequacy Aid and special
education differentiated Aid values to
bring them more in line with the true
much all right folks I ask that we not
be repetitious it seems like we've heard
a lot about school funding more than we
really need to know we know that it's a
problem we don't need to hear it 50
here he's coming later all right how
hello can you hear me yes and you will
be followed by Sue vatnik thank
you please hear me I'm one teeny voice
and I'm advocating for those with a
broken
brain until there is a miracle drug to
help those suffering from chronic and
severe mental illness through New
Hampshire's Community Health and
Behavior Cent centers about 30 years ago
this great state of New Hampshire had a
successful Mental Health System model
and addressed the needs of those
suffering from chronically and severe
mental health brain
disease then the system began to
erode but during the last few years our
system has begun to rebuild its house
New Hampshire's need for strong
community behavioral health centers is
critical for patients to learn how to
manage their lifelong illness like our
brains the mental illness Health Care is
a complex system but now we need to
maintain and protect our solid
foundation in New Hampshire's mental
health system it is not ready to be torn
down it's ready to be built upon I
respectfully urge you all to have heard
me this one tiny person so please don't
pull the blocks out from our New
Hampshire mental health system for
strong F Foundation thank you and I
respectfully
appreciate okay Lynn Peterson followed
vatnik I am Sue
vatnik I think Lynn just went is that
correct yes did I skip did I skip
somebody no she went and then I'm all
right thank you so good afternoon and
thank you for the opportunity to testify
my name is Sue vatnik and I'm a
constituent from Madison New Hampshire
I'm here to testify in opposition to hb1
in
hb2 as a former special education
teacher of 40 years and a mother of
three I care deeply about the future of
all of our children proposals in hb1 and
hb2 threaten the well-being of New
Hampshire's children I won't speak to
the education because there's been some
eloquent conversations about that just
know that I also really oppose the
proposal to increase the voucher system
and want the funding to go to public
education obviously as a special
education teacher I know the value of
public schools healthc care people have
also SP spoken eloquently about the need
to not cut Medicaid that is going to
also really impact the children of our
state housing and Child Care New
Hampshire faces an affordable housing
crisis and yet the proposed budget
eliminates funding for invest New
Hampshire in housing champions making it
harder for families to find affordable
homes they also remove support for
childcare Workforce Development making
quality child care even less accessible
again impacting our children of New
Hampshire and finally energy and our
children's future the budget moves 10
million from the renewable energy fund
to the general fund abandoning clean
energy investment and keeping New
Hampshire relying on fossil fuels the
only New England State to still do so
later is too late to transition to
renewable energy sources too late for
our children's
future I urge you to stand up for New
Hampshire's children and reject these
harmful proposals in hb1 and
hb2 our state budget should prioritize
public education Health Care afford able
housing child care in our children's
future not strip them away thank you for
your
[Applause]
time next will be Lynn Peterson followed
ah thank you all right representative
Wendy
Thomas good afternoon uh Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is representative Wendy Thomas
and I represent the town of marac I also
sit on the science technology and energy
committee today I'll be speaking in
regard to the rating of the $10 million
of the renewable energy fund the
renewable energy fund which is the RF
was created in 2007 as a component of
legislation known as the renewable
portfolio standard which is the RPS
law the RPS mandated that
25.2% of the state's electricity come
from renewable sources by
2025 each year electric service
providers comply with the law by re by
AC I'm Sorry by acquiring renewable
energy certificates or Recs representing
electricity generated from renewable
sources the portfolio requirements
increase over
time electric service providers who
cannot obtain sufficient quantities of
Rex for a given compliance year are
required to make alternative compliance
payments or
acps acps provide the funding for the
renewable energy fund and the purpose of
which is to support thermal and
electrical renewable energ energy
initiatives the RAF administered by the
New Hampshire Department of energy
distributes funds through renewable
energy rebate programs or competitive
Grant
solicitations the RAF provides funding
for the following programs residential
electrical renewable energy rebate
program residential solar hot water re
uh water heating program residential
Central wood pellet boiler furnace
heating program low moderate income
Community solar commercial and
Industrial Solar Technologies cni
Central wood pellet boiler and furnace
programs and cni competitive Grant
programs since its its Inception in in
July 2009 the RAF has dispensed nearly
16 million in cni Project funding
leveraging almost 107 million in private
investment benefiting over 1,100 New
Hampshire businesses on average the RAF
leverages six times more private
investment than public do dollars and
this past year it was a 9 to1 ratio of
private investment versus public subsidy
in fiscal year 24 alone the RAF provided
commercial and Industrial renewable
grants supporting over 60 individual
projects that improved competitiveness
for New Hampshire businesses and
manufacturers while reducing impacts to
taxpayers for municipal and school
projects
since its Inception the RAF has also
benefited more than 11,000 residents
small businesses and municipalities
leveraging over 355 million in private
spending gutting this fund would also
affect our Workforce New Hampshire
currently has around 3,500 workers in
the solar wind hydropower and Woody
biomass Industries these are good paying
jobs that result in Energy savings for
our neighbors and reduce the amount of
money that leads the state to pay for
our out ofate fuels by raiding the RAF
fund and essentially robbing Peter to
pay Paul you will be taking jobs and
business opportunities away from the New
Hampshire residents and work three
minutes let me just lastly you will be
you'll be let me just this one paragraph
lastly you will be violating a
legislative agreement with New Hampshire
taxpayers and stakeholders who supported
the fund with the understanding that it
would be used exclusively for renewable
energy initiatives redirecting funds
like this only leads to an erosion of
public confidence in government fiscal
responsibility I urge you to not raid
you next next will be Jake Reagan
good
afternoon my name is Jake Reagan I'm the
operations manager for Maxim Healthcare
Services branch in Bedford New Hampshire
uh we provide over 120,000 hours of
service every year to families in New
Hampshire um and employ over a 100
caregivers uh private duty nursing is a
continuous skilled nursing care uh
provided in home for medically complex
and vulnerable pediatric and adult
patients uh this is paid for Via
Medicaid and these patients many of whom
require assistance such as ventilators
and tracheostomies require it to sustain
life these individuals require skilled
nursing Services performed in the home
by a registered nurse or a licensed
practical nurse under the supervision of
an RN from between 4 to 24 hours per day
every day in order to manage their
chronic condition
safely Maxim commends the general court
for their support through the pandemic
to provide additional resources to bdn
Providers including rate increases last
budget cycle the rate increases have
been beneficial to recruit and retain
nurses in New Hampshire we've seen
astounding recruiting and retention
results as a result of
this in previous New Hampshire budget
Cycles the lack of proactive investment
in this area created critical access
issues issues for services and left many
patients forced to seek more expensive
care in nursing homes or hospitals at
precisely the time when the capacity was
needed
elsewhere each time provider groups such
as ourselves and parents are forced to
get involved and raise awareness it is
already too
late this committee had the opportunity
and the
responsibility to offer these children
and their families a better way of life
while also helping balance New
maintaining New Hampshire's Medicaid
rates by including a cost of living
adjustment or a cola based on current
market values annually for private duty
nursing would Place New Hampshire's
reimbursement rates comparably with
other New Hampshire Healthcare
Industries and neighboring
states this will have a tangible effect
on children their families and the great
state of New Hampshire surrounding
states have been investing in these
programs by initiating rate studies
along with colas and adjusting their
rates based on these programs or excuse
me and adjusting their rates based on
recommendations from those studies we
urge this committee to stabilize the
Medicaid Program by funding the general
funds with appropriate dollars by
including colas annually this investment
will continue the course of private duty
nursing care in the state and help
protect medically fragile New Hampshire
patients thank you for your support of
home health care we hope that the
committee will consider our request and
maintain PDN reimbursement rates for
private duty nursing so that New
Hampshire care can keep their skilled
you Maggie Larsson will be followed by
Shannon Trembley hello good afternoon I
will be brief to honor all of my uh
fellow New Hampshire people around me I
I'm in admiration of you Maggie Larson
summersworth New Hampshire Schoolboard
chair Community Advocate and I'll say
mother um I have heard what others have
said before me in a mark of a
civilization as famously quoted by Mar
Margaret me is how we care for our most
vulnerable I love our state I love our
country but we need to do better about
how we care for our most
vulnerable it is fiscally necessary and
morally obligatory our governor has
stated honoring our unbreakable
commitment to those in need of our help
reinforces the essential truth and
recognizes that true Equity requires
targeted resources where they're needed
most we must not continue to balance our
budgets on the backs of our most
vulnerable or accepted education system
where Equity remains an aspiration
rather than a
reality I see that our governor has um
has a budget that demonstrates a
willingness to prioritize these values I
want to build upon this Foundation
together collaboratively and further
increase funding for public education
especially special education to create a
truly Equitable system that fully meets
the needs of all students our special
education is a third of our budget we
have um had to cut 16 positions this
year and that includes the trades we are
sinking as a small community that's full
of hardworking people but a lower socio
economic class without property values
so thank you thank you all that have
spoken and I appreciate you listening to
me thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Shannon Trembley followed by Maryanne
barter good afternoon my name is Shannon
Trembley I'm the director of the New
Hampshire Child Care advisory Council um
uh the council we hear from Child Care
Providers every week who are in the
brink of closing due to the lack of
adequate Staffing this will get worse if
the state does not continue to support
the child care Workforce fund which
allow childcare programs to incentivize
teachers to enter and remain in the
field the state knows how effective
these incentives can be as you have used
them to retain other critical Workforce
members in our state such as Corrections
Officers EMTs and recently the state
police the difference between child care
and these other essential Fields is that
we are an economic multiplier for every
teacher who enters or stays in the field
eight parents can go to work those eight
parents will spend money in their
communities and pay taxes to the state
every cent of investment in the
childcare Workforce will be will be
returned to the State
multifold Child Care is one of the
lowest paid Fields fields in the state
with the average teacher making less
than $16 an hour and the wages are lower
than every other state in New England if
we want families to prosper in New
Hampshire we need to give the supports
they need to do so including a VI
you Maryann barter followed by the
Shen Maran is not here
okay Zach shien we've already heard from
most of the members of the school
funding ESS project I hope you will not
be repetitious we have your written
testimony thank you and that will be
followed
by zo Hill or Zoe
Hill good afternoon my name is Zach
shien I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire school funding fairness
project um with respect to the comments
I'll try not to repeat what some of the
folks ahead of me have
said um state budget is an opportunity
to fulfill and fill some of the gap
between what the state has determined to
be the cost of an adequate education
about $5,000 per student and the actual
amount we spend in our public schools
here in New Hampshire upwards of $22,000
per student this lack of funding from
the state creates vast disparities
between what our schools can provide and
between what the property taxpayers have
to foot in each Community about 70% of
all School District Revenue comes from
local property taxes the highest share
in the entire country where only 20%
comes from State source which is the
lowest share in the entire
country hb1 and two present significant
opportuni to start making steps in the
right direction to increase funding for
our Public Schools people all over the
state are demanding that you take this
issue seriously and figure out how to
increase funding for our public schools
around the state we continue to show
that we care deeply about our public
schools that we work hard in our local
communities to walk a very fine line
between balancing the needs of our
students and schools and those are our
taxpayers we're doing this work and we
really appreciate and we hope that the
legislature will step up and meet us in
that effort there are also multiple
recent court rulings that have found
that the system used to fund our Public
Schools is unconstitutional let alone
Decades of other rulings from the
Supreme Court that back up those same
unconstitutional principles were now
operating under just two months ago more
than 1500 people showed up at the
deliberative session in the karge
Regional School District and voted
overwhelmingly to reject an attempt to
slash their budget showing again that
when Grand sters have the opportunity to
engage and show support for the public
schools we overwhelmingly do one month
ago more than 30,000 people signed in
from every single City in town against
an effort to slash the definition of an
adequate education hundred showed up
here to testify against that that
proposal as well and just last night
communities all over the state voted
again and again to reject attempts to
slash their school budgets and supported
increasing funding in their local
schools
there's ample evidence that this is an
issue that Grant Staters care deeply
about and when given the opportunity we
show again and again that we are willing
to invest and and care about our Public
Schools this is not a new issue there's
not a lack of data and I think what I
want to close with is that every child
in New Hampshire should have access to
an excellent fairly funded public
education system regardless of zip code
but this does not mean that we need to
pit this issue against other issues and
there are ways to address all of these
um in a state budget for All Gran
Staters thank you for the opportunity I
apologize for being
[Applause]
late zo Hill followed by Mike
shagu good afternoon Representatives my
name is Zoe Hill I'm a resident of
Lebanon I'm here today to testify an
opposition to proposed Medicaid premiums
growing up Medicaid was how I was able
to get needed medical treatment
including dental care if my parents had
to pay even1 or
$200 I would not have been able to get
the care I needed there are many
children now who like I did are able to
receive needed care because it is free
to them due to Medicaid forcing families
to pay for care previously covered by
Medicaid will harm children in the state
thank you hi my name is Mike shagu and I
have three perspectives I'd like to
share in support of the governor's bill
for funding for folks with disabilities
the first is as a parent I have a son
who has autism and he was diagnosed
early on with Early Intervention when he
was two years old and now he's 25 and
he's working a job and with supported
employment and supported help from job
coaching is able to thrive and be a
member of society uh number two I was a
case manager in um Oregon in Rhode
Island and watching what funding those
two states have compit I don't know here
yet I'm only three years at the voter
here in New Hampshire but realizing the
changes that it made to people with good
funding and the third perspective is um
I'm working right now as a caregiver
because I'm retired with a family in
Alton supported by Lakes Region
Community Services which is great but
these two adults sons are at some point
going to need more care especially
residentials so please keep going going
with the funding and especially toward
residential cuz that's going to never
get better unless we fund
[Applause]
it I guess I've heard these two people
came together Tracy Long and Andrew long
they going to speak either together or
separately
they will be followed by
Barbara
Spike dear chairman and the members of
the New Hampshire house finance
committee uh many my name is Tracy long
I live in Alton I'm here to testify and
urge you to fully fund uh the state
budget for the BDS Bureau of
Developmental services and prioritized
prioritized needs list um my son Andrew
behind me lives with a developmental
disability it's something he was born
with through no fault of his own he is
31 years old um and due to his the lack
of Supportive Housing which the
gentleman before me SP spoke of in New
Hampshire he lives with his parents he
will never drive he will never um be on
his own due to his disabilities however
he does give back to society he's a
redheaded stand-up comic he's respon
he's a responsible Old Navy employee for
over eight years a good voting citizen a
kind funny caring compassionate person
he gives back to his his community by
performing Civic duties he has 12 years
of volunteering at a variety of places
such as the Alton Town Hall the Alton
fire department local libraries dover's
Humane Society to name a few thankfully
New Hampshire has always had a
reasonable support system that has
allowed him to live a life with
dignity uh by being able to access the
community so he can work and volunteer
he is here today and will'll speak about
his job and his standup comedian work
and
volunteering um uh let's the fit the CR
uh funding is critical to Andrew's
continued success and ability to live
outside the confines of his four walls
of his house uh and to live a meaningful
life just like what we all want to have
purpose um I won't go on too long um
let's
see so in order for him to access his
job to be able to shred the old files at
the Alton Town Hall um he needs help to
get them there um without funding Andrew
would be very Andrew's world would be
very small uh I'm aging his father's
aging and we can only do so much never
mind when we won't be here so thank you
for listening please support fully fund
the developmental disabilities and the
you good afternoon chair chman Wier and
members of the house finance committee
my name is Andrew long I am 31 years old
and I moved to alt New Hampshire when I
was
three I I am I'm a voter I vote in all
the elections and I'm here to to testify
why it's why it's I feel it's important
for you to fully support BDS and DD
Services I work at old name
and have been for about 8
years and but and I also worked at
hanford's for around eight years I
volunteer at the Town Hall the Alton
fire station and the um coo he Society
in
Dover I I perform I also do comedy I
even performed at the request of Valerie
sonunu for a state event in
2022 she she she and the governor have
seen me
perform at for the best buddies black TI
Galla several time multiple times I do
assistance the this budget help
basically helps me live my life it helps
me get to my job and my
I and and other essential things in my
life I don't know what I would be doing
without it I would be stuck at home
alone and I don't think that's what you
want for people like
me to be stuck at home and not be able
to be out in the community not be able
to live our lives fully it's essential
to our existence that you that the
proposed budget is fully funded thank
you for giving me the chance to testify
I hope you understand that what what
this really means to me and thousands of
others just like
[Applause]
me Barbara Spike will be followed by
Michelle Carrick
cadis yes good afternoon dear chairman
wer and members of the house finance
committee thank you for hearing us my
name is Barbara Spike and I live in
Plymouth New Hampshire with my son
Charles White I'm a single mother with
no family to lend a hand I urge you to
fully fund Governor aot's proposed state
budget for fiscal years 26 2026 and 2027
and to fund the Bureau of Developmental
Services priority needs list I would
also like support for specifically
funding Family Support Services Charles
would be negatively affected without
funding these Services because of the
services Charles has been able to attend
events with best buddies at Sports and
healthy exercise events including
bowling Zumba walks dances and other
social Gatherings he's been able to have
pure
companionship he has only been able to
work part-time and has for over three
and a half year over three years with
the Market Basket but I have not been
able to work at all because we live in
subsidized housing in Plymouth and we
have for unfortunately for many years
the laws on this subsid housing dictate
an income cap and an asset cap once you
go over either cap you forfeit your
apartment which means
homelessness as housing costs have risen
astronomically in the past few years
with no availability and no reasonable
event re rent even it's if it's found it
leaves Charles and me staying in that
housing this is costly as these
community events and social Gatherings
are often a distance away involving wear
and tear on the car and Charles although
he's a registered voter and has voted he
will never drive in other words we're
stuck but it has only been manageable
because of funding through the Family
Support Services and the Bureau of De
developmental Services thank you
chairman wher and members of the New
Hampshire F house committee for this
opportunity to testify this is Charles
Charles
quickly hi everyone I'm Charles White
and I live in PID New Hampshire with my
mom over here behind me I urge you to
fly to Governor a the proposed state
budget for the 2026 and
27 and the front of the bureau
diment to make it quick my mom has been
able to take me the trips best buddies
and down syndrome team and bowling and
um and the as show the PSU thank you so
much sh Wyman for your support and help
you Michelle Caracus will be followed by
buers hello my name is Michelle kakos
and I'm a marac New Hampshire resident
I'm M of three and I'm the owner and
director of Joyful Noise a Child Care
Center in marac that strives to provide
inclusive quality care I'm here today to
oppose hb1 because they didn't approve
the 15 million Workforce grant for Early
Childhood as they had previously
budgeted my Center received grant money
prior that we've been able to use to
support teacher retention by creating
well-deserved paid days off for our
employees provide telea health benefits
to keep them healthy and in the class
rooms pay for professional development
CPR certifications for all staff and
more importantly provide pay increases
although we'll never be truly paid what
they really deserve but the grant monies
have gone to grow our staff and myself
as
Leaders I'm asking that you reconsider
the budget to write back in for the
grant to support daycare and childcare
centers across all of New Hampshire to
be able to pour into our teachers to
reduce burnout
causing teacher turnover and provide
provision to fuel our teachers to get
their needs met to create a more stable
early childhood education environment
and quality care that our students and
families deserve thank you for hearing
my voice today is this my first time
ever testifying and thank you for your
it Anna buyers followed by by Flo diic
or dapic hello my name is Anna buers I
am acpa and the administrator at e
Learning Center e Learning Center is a
child care center here in conquer we are
licensed for 185 children I am also a
mom of two um ages four and two and I
also am a parent that pays for child
care the weekly tuition for my family
would be $700 a week that is 3,1 $150 a
month that is $36,500 a year why are
these grants important that's what I'm
here to talk about that $5 million
Workforce Grant the way Child Care is
set up in this country it's imperfect
the entire burden RS on the families
that need that need it but everybody
everybody in this room absolutely
everybody benefits from Child Care
without it we wouldn't have a Workforce
as it stands New Hampshire has one of
the highest living costs in the nation
most families can't afford housing can't
afford pretty much to live here
definitely cannot afford to have a
stay-at-home parent without this grant
Child Care becomes more and more
inaccessible to families that
desperately need it we are and we are
unable without this grant we're unable
to retain and recruit staff we sent out
a um a letter to our parents last week
that said in 2024 East Side Learning
Center received various one-time
governmental grants these were
specifically targeted to address the
various challenges childcare providers
are facing with staff vacancy staff
retention and increased cost across the
board we recognize that the cost of
child care is a tremendous burden to
families and these Grant funds
essentially subsidized our personal cost
and enabled us not to charge families
the full cost of operating the center
with the Ever Changing political climate
we cannot rely on this grants these are
not in the
budget as such we are making difficult
changes to our Center that it's
affecting 185
children at the end of the day to have a
thriving economy in New Hampshire you
have to have the infrastructure to
support it and that starts with child
care without child care you don't have a
Workforce no matter what at the end of
the day someone will be paying for this
whether it be the families with
increased tuition cost with un higher
unemployment rates without a Workforce
someone at the end of the day will be
paying for not supporting Child Care
thank
Glenn good afternoon chairman Wier and
members of the house finance committee
my name is Flo daffis I'm a senior at
Hopkin and high school and also a
student representative to the school
board in front of you is the
aforementioned letter with 240
signatures from local elected leaders
including myself calling on the state of
New Hampshire to increase its funding
for public
education currently the way that New
Hampshire funds Public Schools means
that local proper property values
determine how high the property tax
burden is on residents and also the
quality of the education for the kids
there last year you see it cost
$2,545 to educate each student but the
state contributed just $
5,148 per student and that's not enough
some towns were able to close that Gap
easily some like mine had to raise
property taxes significantly and by no
fault of their own some towns were not
able to close that Gap because you did
not step up to pay for their education
the students in these towns were the
ones who paid for it themselves by
losing out on opportunities and
resources in their
schools the vast majority
85% of New Hampshire students attend
public schools there are over 160,000 of
us and we can't vote we can't choose
where we live or where we go to school
but we all deserve and not not just
deserve but are constitutionally
entitled to an adequate education we
will be in school while you write and
vote on this budget so it is your job to
represent us please consider my
testimony in this letter as you work on
good afternoon chair and members of the
house finance committee my name is Nancy
Glenn and I serve on the suton select
board I'm here to express my strong
support for increased State funding for
public education and to Echo the voices
of the 240 local elected officials from
88 municipalities across New Hampshire
who have signed on to a letter that
that's representing a broad and
bipartisan Coalition of school board
members Selectmen budget committee
members and eight of New Hampshire's
nine Mayors together these leaders
represent over 990,000 738 students in
67 school districts more than half of
the state's Public School population if
you're wondering where ston New
Hampshire is we are located in the karge
district go cougars so you can imagine
why it is important for me to be here
today to represent my
constituents our message is simple the
state is not fulfilling its obligation
to adequately fund public education and
it's pushing the burden onto local
property taxpayers in small towns like
mine in Sutton this means difficult
choices whether to cut essential
programs delay building repairs or
further raise property taxes on Working
Families like mine we need a budget that
ensures students across New Hampshire no
matter their zip code have access to the
education that they deserve that's why
this that was just put in front of you
thank you to the student that also
shared her story as well is so
incredibly important and it's not just a
collection of signatures it's a call to
action from those of us on the front
lines of local school funding decisions
we see the personal impacts these
choices have on students in our schools
and the taxpayers in our communities and
I understand the frustration in regards
the repetition of hearing from all of us
about the importance of funding Public
School Ed
education I too share your frustration
in the the repetitious nature that our
state legislature has State Legislature
has done in continuing to put forward
bills to continue to defund public
school education so I can empathize with
you on that so I urge you to listen to
the voices of local leaders to the needs
of our students and to pass a budget
that provides real sustainable
investment in public education thank you
thank
you Lara lavali Laura lavali followed by
Mary
rur hello thank you for allowing me to
speak today I am from Meredith New
Hampshire and I represent myself as a
taxpayer I'm not in the school system I
don't have children in the school system
but aair times call for drastic changes
and I apologize in advance I support an
adequately funded public school system
and I'm opposed to the EFA I apologize I
know you've heard it I would ask are you
listening Have you listened to us Have
people we can't continue to make Cuts in
our Revenue at the beginning it was
stated that Governor aot's budget is
$800 million
off at that point what do you do you
need to number one reinstate the
interest and dividends tax and you need
to not pass HB
1422 which gives it's called the
consumer Relief act but it really just
reduces business profit tax business
Enterprise tax the Communication Service
tax and meals and rooms tax now if you
live here you might pay a restaurant tax
but you're not paying meals and rooms
right so here's the deal if you pass
that bill by the time it's fully
implemented it will have cost it a
reduction in the state general and
education trust funds of
$374 million per year so if 800 million
is off imagine 1.1
billion i i as far as I feel the state
is not doing its job to fund the the
actions that are needed for the people
of this state and you're kicking the can
down the road to property taxpayers we
cannot fund every single thing in the
state while you lower taxes for the
wealthiest and you pay for vouchers for
people who already are sending their
kids to public school so I know the
state has a lot of problems that have to
be tackled housing Child Care employment
you can't bring people into this state
if they can't afford to live here and if
they can't find child care and if the
schools aren't supported well enough
they won't want to come so again I thank
you you I've never spoken like this
before but I thank you for the time and
I hope you listen truly listen to what
everybody here has been telling you
because we need this we are constituents
thank you and have a great
[Applause]
[Music]
day Mary robur followed by Aon delloo
good afternoon representative Wier and
members of the committee I want to thank
you for giving me this opportunity to
testify my name is Mary Roberge and I am
a resident of Manchester District 26 I'm
an active volunteer with AARP New
Hampshire and I deeply believe in aarp's
three budget priorities that support
family caregivers and allow people to
receive community-based care as they
age family caregivers are the 168,000
people in New Hampshire who assist loved
ones with chronic disabilities or
serious health conditions they provide
2.8 billion in unpaid labor annually I
know firsthand how important such
support can be as my mom's caregiver I
would visit my mom every day after work
and help her with getting what she
needed be it her prescriptions her
groceries taking her to her doctor's
appointments or to visit friends so that
she could remain active within her
community programs that keep people at
home and out of costly nursing homes
save taxpayers billions of dollars every
year AARP New Hampshire has three
priorities fund the New Hampshire family
caregiving programs it
helps I'm sorry it provides information
and respit care for those assisting
loved ones with Alzheimer and other
dementias allowing caregivers to address
their own needs and prevent
burnout please fund service link it
serves as a single entty point for
long-term Support Services it offers
information and counseling to help
families navigate their care options
and three fund the choices for
independent program it is a fiscally
responsible way to care for New
Hampshire's oldest adults and empowers
caregivers preventing costly
institutional care and fosters a
healthier more resilient New Hampshire
these programs support family caregivers
and enable community-based care which is
a financially prudent for the state
please vote to keep funding in this
budget and thank you for this
[Applause]
opportunity next Aaron delloo followed
by
Edward could be Shaun C or something
close hi my name is Aon
delloo I live in mil in gwn I work at St
St Teresa's Nursing Home in Manchester
I was born with a brain and body that do
not
work like other people's this means I
need extra help to work harder to learn
things to be
independent I want you to know that the
I want you to know that the kind of
people you budg the kind of people that
budget support like
me I'm involved in the community through
my job with elderly
I'm volunteer at the animal
shelter I'm a registered
voter I have a library card last year I
grew my own vegetables in my
garden my direct support person who's
funded by your budget only works with me
five hours a week but helps me to
achieve all these things along with
other to achieve all these things and
along with to help of my parents
lifetime at independence without my DSP
this wouldn't be possible thank you for
your
time good afternoon my name is Ed Shan
Shala um say the name Shan Shala okay
thank you it'll be probably the only
person you'll ever meet with that name
by the way uh so I'm the CEO of Amin
Community Health Center um is a
federally qualified Health Center in
Northern New
Hampshire uh 26 towns 30,000 residents
we see one in three of the residents um
I won't read the testimony to you have
it in front of you I'll just hit some
highlights so when we invest in primary
preventive Health Care the return on
investment is
$13 as a fiscal conservative it's hard
to find something especially in today's
stock market that's going to give you
that kind of return so to good
investment and it's an investment in
your friends your families your
neighbors yourselves because I think we
all want to be healthy for a variety of
reasons we want to go to our son's
baseball day our our daughter's
graduation you know so most of why we
want to stay healthy is because of
relationships or you want to hike in the
White Mountains things like that when we
look at
Medicaid um the return on investment
really is a economic multiplier for
every dollar of Medicaid there's a
there's a three-fold economic multiplier
so if we put that in human terms for
amusa Community Health Services the SE
approximately 9,000 patients um that's
about
1300 um care visits for the granite
state program so I I really think that's
a significant investment in the health
and wellness of our friends and
neighbors and our families uh they they
work in New Hampshire a lot of them are
small business owners and if they're not
healthy uh they may not have the bench
depth to to have a waitress or to have a
a cashier or to have a mechanic at the
uh at the automobile shop uh so um
lastly I'll point you to the second page
because I had a chance to speak with
some patients about you know what does
health insurance matter for you in this
instance Medicaid but it could be
Medicare it could be something off of
the marketplace and what does it mean to
be well and healthy so there's just a
sampling of those for you and just one
last thing I am the product of public
education from an Appalachian Economic
Development Zone um so I hope that
you're pleased with a return on that
investment of people who were older than
I was who saw the value in investing in
my education I hope that working in a
community health center I'm giving back
to the community so I would encourage
you to invest in uh the health and
wellness of the children because uh they
will be making my end of life decision
and I prefer them to be really smart so
Pike good
afternoon I don't apologize for
repeating some of what other people have
said it's just too important my name is
Deb Nelson and I serve on the Hanover
and Dresden school boards I am also by
the way a retired public school teacher
I regret that my public colleagues did
not include teachers in their concerns
about retirement
benefits but I am here today to
underscore the urgency of New
Hampshire's school funding crisis and to
emphasize
the concerns of my colleagues who have
signed the letter that you received
already as you know leaders from 88
municipalities and 67 school districts
signed that letter its signers include
as you know members of school boards
select boards town councils and budget
committees we see the consequences
of our current funding system which is
failing our
taxpayers every
day in Hanover we are very fortunate as
I think probably a lot of you know to
have a very strong local tax
base and this
unfortunately many communities across
the state are not in a similar position
and you've heard many of them speak to
you today and this
imbalance this
misbalance this inequity matters to me
and my colleagues it is a sorry
statement about public education in New
Hampshire that many other districts do
not have the resources we
do towns with lower property values are
struggling to provide even the most
basic educational opportunities for
their students the current system forces
communities into a lose lose choice
either raise property taxes to make up
for inadequate state aid or cut critical
programs but our students
need we need our students deserve our
families want our communities ask for a
budget that meets the state's
constitutional obligation to fund public
education fairly and
adequately the letter before you is more
than a set of signatures it's a
resounding call from those of us
responsible for making School budgets
work we need the state you folks to make
a meaningful investment in our Public
Schools our students and our taxpayers
cannot afford wait thank you I was going
to the end of my
sentence thank
[Music]
gibart again I don't think we need to
hear a hundred times about school
[Applause]
[Music]
Mi Mr chairman in the committee thank
you good afternoon my name is Heather
Pike I'm from Pittsfield New
Hampshire the testimony I gave you was
several pages but uh I have made a
condensed version so I don't go
over I'm here to speak about
Medicaid for those who are
disabled Medicaid is an Irreplaceable
Lifeline not only for them but their
families also those who are
working but who cannot afford to pay for
private insurance I'm going to give
testimony today from my own family
stories one from each end of the
spectrum of those young adult New
Hampshire citizens who rely on Medicaid
for their Mental Health
Services one is a four-year one story is
about a four-year college graduate
currently
self-employed after several draining
years of trying to establish as a
professional working with children with
autism Co hit and they were back living
at home until clinical depression took
them out of life's hope and engagement
unable to afford Medical Care loved ones
stepped in to help this young adult get
Medicaid funded Insurance thanks to the
expansion and mental health care so now
they have re-entered the stream of life
and picked up on building their dreams
as young adults should Medicaid funded
insurance gave them access to mental
health care it was Health Care access
that put this young person in position
to re-enter their world world and get
back working again not the other way
around
around the second story is another loved
one living with complex medical issues
including an intractable and
lifethreatening mental illness who
relies on Medicaid for services and
supports for aspects of daily living and
health care this person lives in a rural
area with very few options or resources
to basic access for things we all hold
dear like most people in their position
they are a pedestrian and they rely on
the CTS through Medicaid for their
transportation to their medical
appointments this person also relies on
a Community Mental Health Center a case
manager to interface for all their use
of Center services but as one case
manager noted with about 65 clients a
piece these clients who need more than
basic Services there is no way
realistically to make that happen
sustainably so I'm speaking here of the
Community Mental Health carees wanting
to provide much
needed services but they cannot because
of the uncompensated categories for
services so that's one of my emphasis is
that I ask you to address those and when
you read my testimony you look in the
middle of it there's a little Easter egg
in there about what will surprise you
about what's not
compensated no one none of us are immune
from illness or Misfortune that can lay
us low or cause us to lose all we
thought we had control over three
minutes never know
health is the first wealth please do
what you can to help it in the budget
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you Susan Sterns followed by Danielle
Robinson
good afternoon chairman Wier members of
the committee for the record my name is
Susan Sterns and I'm a resident of
sbert in the interest of full disclosure
I am employed as executive director of
Nami New Hampshire however I am not here
today in that role rather I am here as a
family member of a loved one living with
a mental
illness my family member is 53 years old
and has been living with this severe and
persistent illness since his late teens
he receives Social Security benefits
accesses Mental Health Care through his
local Community Mental Health Center and
has lived in his own small apartment for
many years thanks to a Section 8 Housing
Voucher due to his disability he has
significant challenges managing money so
his father is his legal representative
pay making sure that his rent and
utilities are always paid on time and
that he has food after paying all his
bills my loved one has $4 a day in
spending money which gives him a small
bit of autonomy that is incredibly
important to him and his mental
well-being he used to be able to
purchase a coffee and donut with his
daily $4 but due to Rising costs he can
no longer afford the
dut of course he did receive a $30 month
Cola increase from Social Security at
the beginning of the year as a result
his Section 8 Housing Voucher was
reduced by $32 a month it's not even a
zero sum game
folks you might think my loved one's
financial situation is exceptional
because of his very limited means it is
sadly
exceptional because he does have
subsidized housing and thanks to his
father's careful management he has $4 a
day in his pocket something that allows
him to meet his one friend and have a
cup of
coffee for people like my loved one
living with a severe and persistent
mental illness even the smallest
increase in something like a
prescription co-pay will have a
significant
impact my loved one has family who will
help him of course many people living
with serious mental illness do not
however and the outcomes for many will
likely be not being able to fill
prescriptions resulting in far more
costly interventions such as
hospitalization I know that the task
before you is very difficult I ask that
you remember people like my loved one
whose financial situation makes them
especially vulnerable to even the
smallest changes in income and I thank
you for your steadfast service to our
Susan excuse me Susan Sterns followed by
Danielle Robinson you're Susan I'm
Danielle say that again that's Susan I'm
Danielle oh I already called Susan yep
all right so now it's Danielle Robinson
thank you yep good afternoon my name is
Danielle Robinson and I'm here to speak
on behalf of the families children and
child care providers who depend on the
the New Hampshire childcare scholarship
program at the ark Learning Center we
have three locations in Tilton hookit
and Londoner and we see firsthand the
impact of this program in Tilton alone
55% of my families rely on it to afford
safe quality and child quality Child
Care while they work while this program
is essential it's not without its flaws
managing it requires a dedicated staff
member spending multiple hours a week
just on billing tracking attendance
obtaining signatures and monitoring for
a sudden SC scholarship link sudden
something that happens without warning
over 90% of time the scholarship link
will drop without warning the because
these funds are paid retroactively when
the link drops families suddenly face an
average unexpected bill of
$900 forcing them to pull their child
from care this leads to job loss
disrupted care and providers losing
tuition they were counting on enrollment
delays create further hardship it can
take weeks for a scholarship link to
appear meaning families must either pay
out of pocket or delay starting their
new job this system is not working for
the people it was meant to help at the
same time we must address the challenges
facing our teachers the state expanded
funding through the workforce assistance
pilot program yet the process to access
these funds is so burdensome that it's
failing those it was meant to help at
the ark we provide free child care to
all of our teachers this cost us
$270,000 in
2024 this was a benefit that we hoped
that this program would help us be able
to sustain however in the 3 months that
this pilot program has been working zero
out of my 15 teachers have been approved
and one of our teachers that was
previously approved for the scholarship
program had her link drop suddenly with
no explanation and no change of
financial status so I guess we can say
negative one teachers has benefited from
this program everyone is stuck in an
endless cycle of paperwork resubmissions
and rejections even when they can Pro
prove that they submitted the required
documents the process is so convoluted
that teachers must apply through the
regular scholarship program get denied
then start over entirely once denied
facing more paperwork more interviews
and more barriers for our teachers run
the regular New Hampshire childcare
scholarship program their cost Shares
are so high that the arc is still
covering over 50% of their child's
tuition if we truly value child care as
an essential service one that keeps
parents working and strengthens our New
Hampshire economy then we must reduce
the barriers not create more the New
Hampshire childcare scholarship program
must continue but with improved
accessibility and the workforce
assistant pilot project must continue
but be reformed to actually work for the
Educators it was designed to support our
families need this our teachers need
this let's work together to make sure it
Rob NATO and I discovered a card here
someone they had to leave early is Stacy
Curtis
here what was it what was
that Robo spoke thank you how about
Stacy Curtis has she been here she left
sheath and she'll be followed by
good afternoon my name is Nicole sheath
and I am a resident of exitor I am here
on behalf of my four children with
Developmental and mental health
disabilities I ask that you oppose the
current budget and modify it to match
requests from the Bureau of
Developmental services and Bureau of
mental health 5 years ago before the
pandemic I was forced to quit my job as
an occupational therapist of 20 plus
years only to Prov provide care and
Service Coordination for my children as
we did not yet have access to inhome
Services we relied on Medicaid for
healthc care as I carried private
insurance when I left my young daughter
required several residential placements
during this time and received
life-saving mental health treatment she
is now home and thriving my 20-year-old
son graduated high school three years
ago with honors due to receiving
appropriate supports and services he
transitioned to Adult Services and
waited a year to find Direct Service Pro
providers due to the in inadequate staff
and salary
funding he had about three to five about
five direct service providers over the
past year was doing excellent at his job
and then during gaps when our service
providers left was asked to leave his
supportive
employment he currently ass sitting at
home non not contributing to the economy
nor living a fulfilled life still
waiting for Staffing here is a smart and
able young adult who can positively
impact his community and he is not he is
excited to live away from home learning
how to manage his own apartment with
on-site staff support but without
funding residential options this takes
away his ability to live
independently this also wa takes away my
ability to go back to work and we lost
half of our
income currently rent an exiter for a
one-bedroom apartment is $2,000 a month
there is no way he can afford this
there's no way I can build an Adu to
have them live in my
house I ask you to help children and
adults like mine live their best lives
by funding a budget requests of the
Bureau of Developmental and Mental
Health Services thank you
[Applause]
brabeck good evening chairman Wier and
members of the house finance committee
my name is McKenzie Nicholson I have the
pleasure of being the senior director
for moms rising in New Hampshire a
community of moms parents and caregivers
across New Hampshire who are deeply
invested in the future of our families
our Workforce and our economy budgets
aren't just numbers they're moral
documents they show show us what we
value the decisions made in this budget
will shape the health stability and the
economic future of New Hampshire's
families here's what we're asking of you
invest in child care because parents
can't work without it parents in New
Hampshire are facing a crisis when it
comes to child care Working Families are
struggling to afford it and providers
who are the workforce behind the
workforce cannot make ends meet without
continued investment we risk losing more
child care providers pushing parents out
of the workforce and stalling our econom
growth we need sustainable Child Care
Solutions that allow our families to
thrive and our economy to function
protect Medicaid because health is not a
Lifeline excuse me protect Medicaid
because Healthcare is not a life is a
Lifeline not a luxury over 170,000
Granite Staters including children
pregnant people uh families rely on
Medicaid Cuts in these proposed changes
would mean fewer families accessing
life-saving care more strain on
hospitals and worse health outcomes
across our state protecting Medicaid
isn't just the right thing to do it's a
fiscally responsible investment in
public health I'm also asking that you
preserve funding for Family Resource
Centers because strong families mean
strong communities Family Resource
Centers provide crucial support
parenting classes maternal mental health
screenings home visiting programs and
more these centers are lifelines for
families facing the most facing their
most challenging days cutting this
funding would be devastating especially
in the mid middle of a growing maternal
Health crisis we want to keep families
babies supported and we want to keep
strong communities we must keep these in
Investments intact lastly keep public
education dollars where they belong in
public schools New Hampshire's public
schools are the hearts of our community
every dollar diverted away from them
weakens the system that the vast
majority of our kids use our teachers
students and schools need resources not
roadblocks public tax dollars should
stay in public schools to ensure that
every child no matter which town they
live in gets access to a high high
quality
education moms parents and caregivers
across New Hampshire are watching this
budget process closely I know because
we're bringing it to them we're making
it more accessible answering their
questions their concerns hearing them
you may find me repetitive but this is
the people's house and in the moms that
I'm talking to they don't feel heard
because hearings like these happen
during the middle of the workday with
only 5 days notice that doesn't just
shut families out of the process it
shuts out the very people that these
decisions impact the most and those
decisions matter they determine whether
young families can afford to stay move
here and build a future in New Hampshire
it's not just about those families it's
about the future of our Workforce and
our economy and our communities we urge
you prioritize funding for child care
protect Family Resource Centers keep
Medicaid strong ensure public dollars
stay in public schools moms are watching
Megan brabeck followed by Oscar
lawit
lit good afternoon my name is Megan
brabeck tothill I live in New Market and
I'm here today with save the children
Action Network to talk about child care
first I want to share a story um from
Laura Lee Baker a childcare director
from in who wasn't able to join us here
today she shared that she first started
in the workforce in 2003 but had to
leave once she had kids due to the high
cost of care for her own
kids she said quote despite these
challenges I remained committed to my
career working hard to earn my degree in
early childhood education while
balancing the responsibilities of being
a mother in 2012 I took the opportunity
to further my education and by 2014 I
graduated and began working as a lead
educator as at a Childcare Center
however I quickly found that despite my
degree the pay was still insufficient to
support my family forcing me to leave
the field again she's bounced in and out
of the field since then until she got a
director role in
2023 you've heard wages for early
educators are low and yet child care in
the granite state is unaffordable for
most Working Families I want to share
some polling information recent polling
of granite Staters shows that nearly
three in four voters believe the state
should be doing more to support Working
Families by improving access to quality
affordable care 86% of Voters view
funding for the child care and preschool
system as a good investment of taxpayer
money this is not a partisan issue it's
a family and Workforce issue that's why
I urge you to take three steps in this
budget first protect Investments of the
childcare scholarship program nearly
nine in 10 voters support maintaining
funding for this
program second extend the child care for
child care workers pilot Beyond 6 months
this is not enough time as you've heard
to fully assess its impact we need at
least a year to allow workers to learn
about the program apply and for us to
gather meaningful data on its efficacy
if we want to solve the Staffing crisis
in childcare we need Sustainable
Solutions not quick fixed programs that
disappear before they can make a
difference and lastly please restore the
$15 million childcare Workforce fund
this fund was created to support Child
Care Professionals by providing grants
for bonit bone bonuses benefits and
professional development right now even
the most experienced Child Care
Professionals often earn less than the
federal poverty level the average pay is
$15 an hour less than most fast food
jobs this low pay is a major reason why
so many childcare programs have long
weight lists and cannot meet demand
investing in the childcare Workforce
fund is a direct investment in the
stability of our child care system 82%
of Voters support continued State
funding to recruit and retain childcare
teachers and and nearly two in three
voters so they would have a less
favorable view of their legislature if
they vote to cut this funding I urge you
to make the right choice for New
Hampshire families and our economy and
you Oscar tell me the pronunciation last
name Lovich Lovich thank you we'll be
followed by Deborah house wonderful good
afternoon everybody my name is a lawitz
I have lived in New Hampshire my entire
life and I'm currently a junior up at
Plymouth State University I'm studying
political science up there and I'm here
today to express my concerns for the
proposed budget cuts that would include
programs at my
University Plymouth State University is
currently seeking to cut its budget by
2% and has provided a working plan to do
this but that would fire 30 faculty
members and greatly reduce the
humanities Department this is a
temporary solution to a larger problem
that we're facing uh a solution that
will not hold forever uh I expect that
the solution will not hold for the next
5 years these budget cuts will not stop
at just the humanities when Plymouth
state is again faced in another five
years with budget cuts they will look to
the most to the next group of the most
vulnerable
Majors after that they will go to the
next group and then the next I believe
that Plymouth State University will be
budgeted out of existence in the next 15
years these budget cuts will not just
kill Plymouth State University
University but will strangle the many
small businesses that rely on the
student body to keep their doors open
these budget cuts will destroy the
unique community that has developed
between the campus and the town
dismantling the decades long
relationships formed between local
organizations and campus groups the
budget cuts will destroy the majority of
student organizations primarily ran by
Humanities Majors these programs make
Plymouth the Charming campus that
invites new students to take a chance on
Plymouth
State I implore you all to Recon
consider the future of New Hampshire's
Youth and prioritize our education and
pass on to the next Generation the great
state that I was able to grow up in
thank
you jebra house followed
brassett good afternoon chairman Wier
members of the house finance committee
my name is Deborah how I am president of
the American Federation of teachers New
Hampshire uh and yes I am here to talk
about education funding if you didn't
want to hear about it then perhaps you
can fix it in this budget and we won't
have to repeat this in two years um I
will try and summarize because I do have
written testimony to hand in so we are
here to oppose this budget as it is
currently written and we hope that you
will make great strides in bringing the
state into constitutional compliance
with its duty to all granted State
children all granted State children have
the constitutional right to a robust
public education uh in in their school
district and the state has the
obligation to fund it right now our
current funding model relies about 70%
on local property taxes 20% on state
revenue and as of at least yesterday
about 9% on federal sources we don't
know what's happening with that um
because of that we have a very
varied um experience in our public
education from District to District to
the point where um in some schools you
have a wide variety of say advanced
placement classes that students can take
in high school and other uh districts
they can't hire and retain Math teachers
in the high school they have to do a
virtual option where the teacher is not
available in person to help students who
are stuck on something um and and they
have teachers who cannot differentiate
lessons for students with special needs
for students who come from a different
language background but all of those
students have the right to take math
class class in high school that is not a
robust public education it's not even a
basic public education when you can't
provide that so we want you to really
make strides on fixing this funding
formula even though we know revenues are
limited that's a whole other discussion
that I heard someone address very well
here um the second thing we do realize
there is more funding in there for
special education grants but not enough
it only meets the needs as they were two
years ago those are needs to support
extraordinary um needs for support that
students have to access their public
education but it's always a year behind
and what the governor budgeted for is
what was needed two years ago costs have
gone up in the last two years districts
need more than that right now and they
will need more going forward so even
though the governor put more in in her
budget it's not enough you're going to
keep
pitting um special educ a needs against
what's the rest of the school budget and
cause that hollowing out of your already
skimpy education to the detriment of all
students the third thing expanding
vouchers providing a robust public
education is a constitutional right for
every student and a constitutional Duty
for this legislature paying for the
private educational choices of Granite
State families is a choice this
legislature made paying for it is not
something you have to do when revenues
are limited you don't make extra
expenses you don't pay extra you don't
go out shopping on a shopping spr okay
last thing University system we just
heard about it don't cut that further
our grand State families deserve an
instate choice that they can afford to
send their children to it so they will
[Music]
Lee good
afternoon members of the house finance
committee thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak with you today my
name is Katie br and I work with an
organization called Early Learning New
Hampshire we are a Statewide nonprofit
and part of our mission is to support
Early Childhood programs such as Head
Start Child Care preschool after school
and the children and families that they
serve I won't I'll cut my comments down
a little bit because I agree with a lot
of the child care uh information that
you've heard already today but I did
want to briefly just share that some of
the things that we're hearing from the
field for the past five years twice a
month we hold Zoom calls with the Child
Care community and On Any Given meeting
there can be over a 100 providers
attending and really sharing what's
going on uh at their programs and over
the years since covid we've pulled and
surveyed our attendees just to kind of
get a better sense of what they're
experiencing without fail the number one
issue that we have heard has been
Staffing both retaining and recruiting
good teachers to work in these programs
this has been the biggest challenge
above all and we know and you heard that
other Industries are facing a Workforce
crisis and we understand that but what's
different about child care is that we
are the workforce behind the workforce
so we know New Hampshire businesses are
relying on these programs so that their
employees can show up every day to
work today I am asking you to restore
the $115 million for the childcare
Workforce so these programs can keep
their doors open so that they can rain
and recruit good teachers and so that
they can provide this essential service
for New Hampshire citizens we cannot
time John Lappy or Lai followed by
correct me uh Lappy Lappy followed by
Lisa Bowden right thank you uh my name
is John Lappy I'm a professor of
political science at Plymouth State and
I'm here to express my concerns for what
proposed higher education uh funding
Cuts will do to our University
plymouth's mission is to provide a
quality affordable and personal college
education I can tell you from personal
experience many of our students come in
rough around the edges 37% of our
instate students are first generation
who tend to need a bit more guidance
some of them like I was myself as a teen
maybe didn't do great in high school
having the talent but maybe they weren't
mature enough yet or they just weren't
challenged or inspired and we provide
the kind of environment those students
need some institutions have large class
sizes Professor lectures to them they
don't know the students and for some
students that works fine but it doesn't
work for ours we know who our students
are the faculty student ratio at
Plymouth is 1 to 17 so one fat Professor
for every 17 students when they struggle
or they do well or need a little
encouragement we see them in our major
classes we're usually see those students
twice a week every week every semester
until they graduate and that's what many
of our students need the Personal Touch
they were always capable but they needed
to be
seen an article in the New Hampshire
Business Review among other show sources
shows our state is last in State
financial support for higher education
but we are also as reported in Forbes
and the College Board the second highest
instate tuition rate in the country and
those rates are set to go up even as our
budget is set to be cut even as there
are proposals to eliminate up to 30
faculty positions that 16% of our
faculty and the permanently shutter
eight programs we are going to be
offering our young people a lower
quality education with fewer choices
less knowledge less skills at higher
cost as of 2022 58% of New Hampshire
High School grads who went to college
went out of state and that is the
highest rate in the country
and it's easy to see why as of today
instate students at Plymouth are charged
15,000 a year tuition and fees as New
England residents they could enroll in
one of 33 programs at Southern Maine
just as an example for 19,000 and if
these Cuts go through other institutions
are going to be offering more choice and
I think as Granite Staters we need to
ask what do we need to do to give the
students of our state the education they
deserve and what are we offering them to
stay in our state thank you
[Applause]
Leno good afternoon I am here in two
capacities I am currently serving as the
half time executive director of the New
Hampshire Council of churches which is
calling for a moral budget and the New
Hampshire Council of churches doesn't
see the budget as proposed as a moral
budget and that test that written
testimony is submitted I am also here
today in my
capacity um again for the record my name
is Lisa Bodwin in my capacity as a mom
and as a Disability Policy expert I want
to tell you that I support the
governor's call for a for fully funding
the developmental Disability Services
line items however I cannot in good
conscience support the
budget because a budget that calls for
Medicaid premiums and co-pays is going
to harm the families who at the highest
rates in our nation fall out of the
middle class and into poverty and those
are disability families disability
families across New Hampshire have to
leave employment as Nicole just told you
and as Barbara also told you earlier and
families are already paying somewhere on
the order I mean I'm sorry giving
$339 million a year on nights and
weekends to the state of New Hampshire
in uncompensated care for those
individuals with Developmental and
intellectual disabilities who need
round-the-clock
care I want to remind the finance
committee that RSA 171a mandates that
the New Hampshire legislature fully fund
the adult developmental disability
service system people with disabilities
must have the support they are entitled
to by state law in order to participate
in the American dream to share their
strengths and talents to work and people
with disabilities can and do want to
work and be robustly engaged in their
home communities Medicaid is not only a
vital safety net it is one of the most
coste effective Investments New
Hampshire can
make medic Home and Community Based
service waivers allow people with
disabilities as you've heard to do all
sorts of things in their communities I
won't repeat but what I do want to tell
you is the
alternative is institutional or
congregate setting care which is
infinitely far more expensive group
homes are about
$112,000 a year and if New Hampshire
returns to congregate settings that's
$225,000 a year per person Medicaid HCBS
waiver money is a
bargain when Services aren't funded
adequately families are forced to step
in as unpaid caregivers which I just
mentioned this is an unsustainable and
unjust burden that no responsible
government should allow to continue it
is in fact a form of
exploitation let's be clear supporting
full funding for Adult Services is not
about
compassion it is a it is a matter of
fiscal responsibility and legal
compliance fully funding Medicaid HCBS
is the most efficient use of New
Hampshire taxpayer dollars when we fund
Services properly we stabilize families
prevent a return to costly
institutionalization and B New
Hampshire's economy by allowing family
caregivers to remain in the
workforce three
minutes you can read the rest of my
testimony
all right next is representative David
Leno I've been given a card that I think
I called before it did Laquisha gibart
already
speak did you already speak I all right
you'll be you'll be next great thank you
very much Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record Dave luno
representing the people of bow and
Hopkinson uh many of you probably know
why I'm why I'm up here to uh to speak
this afternoon uh and it's specifically
on the education Freedom account program
and the proposed expansion um of that of
that program uh want to talk a little
bit about the estimated costs but first
as you're aware this is a program where
the state gives families $5 to $9,000 a
year as long as their child does not
attend public schools so the thing is uh
Mr chair the uh the takeup rate on this
program is very low very low and um uh
and it's about 220 250 kids out of the
160,000 um uh students that attend New
Hampshire Public Schools um I mean after
all most of these kids want to be with
their friends and teachers they don't
want to uh they don't want to leave for5
or $9,000 um um at all but um but of the
22,000 School AG kids that are not in
public schools that particip the
participation rate is very high after
all who's going to leave that type of
cash on the table so there's currently
about 6,000 kids in the program costing
about $30 million a year uh with
virtually no local tax
savings why be because they were already
in non-public you know private um
schools so um the remaining kids uh with
no income cap are very like to take the
cash so costing the state some 60 to 80
million a year and this is a number um
that um uh that's based on information
on the number of of Stu of school age
students that live in New Hampshire but
it's also supported by uh by you know a
for the former member from where and
former chair of this um this committee
so just yesterday the Josiah Bartlet
Center put out an estimate that this
would cost about $5 million well that's
laughable given the uh the de the
demographic data and I urge this
committee to do its job and not wave off
getting a detailed fiscal analysis of
this program I hope you'll look into the
cost associated with this and I hope
you'll find that um expanding to
Universal vouchers is uh is not the
right thing to do at this time thank you
Laquisha Gib correction Laquisha gibart
Campbell hello
everyone good afternoon my name is
Laquisha G
hard I can bend it up thank you good
afternoon I first want to say thank you
so much for allowing me to speak today
I'm coming to you as a mother a resident
and a compassionate and dedicated
hardworking woman these are traits that
I carried with me as I migrated here
from Massachusetts for a better life for
me and my daughter as you see this is
Zana back in the fall of 2022 I never
thought in a million years that I would
be out of work for over a year and half
of the reason was due to lack of child
care availability in the area I live in
Bristol my daughter was able to attend
one facility but was expelled due to
behavioral issues she had when she was
two I was then forced to seek child care
in lonia which in which is 25 minutes
away from where we
live yes M and that also fell through it
was the end of the school year and I put
myself on a waiting list at both Head
Start and a local daycare facility that
was willing to take on my daughter even
though she had just been been diagnosed
with a developmental delay these are
only a few of the trials and
tribulations that I had to go through to
seek reliable child care then came
applying for a child care scholarship
with DHHS which took about 90 days in
total to obtain once obtained I still
had to come up with $300 for the first
two weeks that my daughter would attend
the child care and I ask you this how
can a parent or a family come up with
$300 for child care if they don't even
have income or employment and they're
seeking income and employment while also
seeking Child Care these numbers aren't
adding up I need you to take a hard look
at the paperwork in front of you the
numbers don't lie I'm here as a mother
pleading for you to consider increasing
the funding for this child care
scholarship and somehow allowing it
possible and easier for families to
obtain Child Care affordable child care
so that we can do our due diligence and
be working citizens of New Hampshire
chrisen Campbell will be followed by
Debbie and Zeke
Richardson hi good afternoon my name is
Kristen Campbell and I'm the director of
Health well-being and Independence at
Waypoint which is a nonprofit
organization that Services across the
state of New Hampshire our home care
program provides pcsp hom making LNA and
nursing services to seniors and adults
with disability
by cut in Medicaid this would be
detrimental to Services across the state
as well as the workforce which many
people have expressed concern about I'm
here today in support of ensuring that
adequate CFI funding remains in the
budget in order to fund these essential
services at Waypoint we provide CFI
services to over 400 clients residing in
Hillsboro and marrat County there's an
increased need for this throughout the
state New Hampshire is the second most
AG in state in the US One in five New
Hampshire residents is over the age of
65 there's a cost saving which which
many people have shared CFI saves money
investing in CFI Services is the most
fiscally responsible and conservative
option the cost of CFI Services is
substantially cheaper than
hospitalizations Assisted Living
programs and nursing home a year of CFI
Services cost less than
$20,000 compared to 100 to 150,000 for a
nursing home the system of care CFI
services and Medicaid is a critical
component of our system of care
hospitals are overburdened and unable to
discharge clients due to a lack of
available beds and nursing homes
rehabilitation centers and homebased
care options this has led to Extended
Stays creating a log gym in the system
and ultimately taking away beds from
people who are critically ill the impact
this allows individual ual the ability
to maintain their independence and
dignity within their homes ensures
safety and basic needs are met improves
the overall quality of life mitigates
risks of social isolation Falls and
unnecessary hospitalizations I just want
to share a quick client story as this
client wasn't able to attend today in
March of 2024 we received a referral for
81-year-old female who resides in
Manchester within 72 hours of receiving
the referral we were able to open the
client and begin providing essential
nursing and pcsp services in the
client's home she was extremely highrisk
and medically compromised she had
mobility issues and was a fall risk she
was unable to move without the use of an
assisted device and unable to leave her
home she spent almost a year without
leaving her
home
um she was unable to sorry um she was
unable to leave to do essential errands
such as is grocery shopping laundry and
picking up her medication she was on
24-hour O2 for her COPD she was unable
to bathe and dress
herself ultimately leading to unhygienic
conditions which impacted her overall
health her hair was Madden and her skin
had sores her Livin situation and
overall well-being was just completely
unsafe she was struggling with untreated
mental illness she was at risk of having
to go into a nursing home despite her
wish to stay at home she had a lack of
community support for limited financial
means and no family involvement the
impact can I three minutes can I finish
it's real
quick
um sorry
conclusion basically without our
services she would have been in the
nursing home so
I appreciate the cooperation most of you
are sticking to three minutes or less
we've still got many more to go and it
could be two more hours or more all
right Debbie and Zeke Richardson will be
followed by Dam uh damis
santara thank you so much so I'm here on
behalf of my grandson Zeke Richardson he
just wants to say a few words as best as
he can go ahead
go
um hey
GJ yeah okay so um he just wants to
share his story see stay here with me he
just wants to share his story so he um
was born uh with Down Syndrome but he
has uh multiple GI issues um and he came
to live with us when he was 8 years old
we are his grandparents so um he lives
with u myself and my husband because of
some substance misuse that happened in
the family this is a normal um
unfortunate um case that you see across
the board so we are dealing with
multiple things um because Zeke lives
with us we provide 247 care he's
essentially nonverbal um he needs
assistance with all daily activities but
he has had an amazing life he has had an
excellent uh school system um and
thrived he was known as the mayor of
Newfound uh we live in Alexandria New
Hampshire and um he just absolutely just
thrives everybody in the community knows
him even though he's non-verbal he's
still um just very very active very
involved in the football program um but
when he graduated from high school there
was nothing for him he is part of Lakes
Region community services and although
they did everything that they could to
help us uh we were unable to get
services for him for two years he fell
into a very deep depression this young
man who is so engaged um re just was not
able to communicate his needs he became
very reclusive um he became disruptive
it became very ult unlike anything he
had been his entire life um we were
fortunate enough to get um Services two
days a week it has dramatically changed
him back to the young man that he is
today and he is so happy are you so
happy Zeke so please continue to fund it
because without these services I don't
know where we'd be I am a nurse I work
on the days that he attends these these
uh Community programs he works at hords
um my husband works nights so we provide
as much support as we possibly can but
we need your help in order for him to be
able to do and live and be the best
right did I pronounce the name right
Santa uh Santana a colleague filled it
out for me as I was coming in so that's
what was the first name Damen Damen
thank you he will be followed by
bergham so I just wanted to speak
briefly on the Alcohol fund and I have a
colleague that will be speaking more
directly to the programs that it
supports uh within the public health
networks but as an employee of the
public health networks for the State of
New Hampshire I wanted to talk a little
bit uh more broadly about the work that
we do and what this funding helps to
support so one of the things that the
public health networks do within the
state of New Hampshire is create um
strategic plans to support emergency
response Services throughout the state
so there are 13 networks we cover a
number of towns in each region I cover
24 towns around conquered and our
responsibility uh within those um
networks is to maintain things like
trained volunteers Medical Reserve Corps
volunteers uh emergency response
Services things like that and we we
collaborate and work closely with
Emergency Management directors uh First
Responders multiple departments at
DHHS and we all have a critical role in
responding to emergencies so something
like the covid-19 pandemic we all play a
part in making sure that vaccin
vaccinations and information get out to
the towns in a timely man manner so that
we can address our most vulnerable
populations so this funding is really
critical to supporting these networks
because without that uh pre-existing
infrastructure we would be completely
unprepared to respond to the next public
health emergency whether it's natural
disaster uh or another pandemic for
example so I hope this testimony is
helpful just helping to contextualize
what those networks are for and how they
operate to a certain extent and why the
funding from the alcohol fund is so
helpful in terms of preparing our
communities to better respond to
emergencies thank you
[Applause]
Nesbit good afternoon chairman Wier and
members of the house finance committee
my name is Cindy berson and I'm a
registered nurse with nearly 20 years in
home care I have been with the granite
BNA during that time I have served in
many roles including as a case manager
and now as a a senior director of Home
Care I fell in love with Home Care
Nursing when I job shadowed as part of a
clinical rotation I thought caring for
people in their home environment was the
best way I could serve people it was the
best decision I ever made it is a
privilege to care for individuals in
their homes and in their communities
Granite BNA is the largest certified
home care and hospice agency in New
Hampshire offering personalized services
and programs including ining Home Care
Hospice Pediatric and Maternal Child
Health Services and wellness
programming last year our team
made
141,142
8,039 Home Care patients
45,2 188 visits to
1,250 patients on Hospice
575,000 miles of travel in the state of
New
Hampshire for more than 125 years
Granite BNA has made a critical
difference in the lives of people of all
ages in our community last year we
subsidized Medicaid care for over $1
million this is not sustainable in our
current healthc care landscape a strong
Home Care System benefits the the entire
Health Care system if home and
community- Based Services are adequately
resourced hospitals will be able to
discharge patients this will avoid
bottlenecks in the Health Care System
affecting all of us choices for
independent CFI serves individuals with
nursing home level needs who want to age
in place without these Services many
would have no choice but to enter
institutional Care Home Care and
communitybased care is the fiscally
responsible choice if individuals cannot
receive atome care they will end up in
hospitals or long-term care facilities
which cost thousands more per patient
prior to the last budget cycle CFI was
underfunded by
$153 million leading to provider
closures and service gaps predictable
incremental Medicaid rate increases will
help providers to continue to serve
members of our community Granite vna's
longevity is rooted in our deep sense of
responsibility and commitment to serve
our community nurses and
paraprofessionals providing care to this
population develop therapeutic
relationships that continue for years
this relationship characterized by
empathy and respect allows our staff to
recognize when their patients are
approaching or experiencing a change in
their health status allowing a timely
response avoiding crisis and improved
outcomes
time one second your support ensures New
Hampshire residents of all ages can
receive care in the setting that best
meets their needs safely affordably and
with dignity thank
[Applause]
you Leslie Nesbit
we'll be followed by Kelsey Brook
Emme thank you chairman and members of
the committee I appreciate each and
every one of you for being here waiting
for so long sitting patiently I'm very
uh appreciative of being a proud New
Hampshire native my name is lesle nesbet
I'm here today as someone who is deeply
committed to building stronger
communities in our state I'm also here
as the Grantham School District board
chair speaking on behalf of my entire
School Board we are fir firmly rooted in
the mission of advocating for all of New
Hampshire's children who deserve every
opportunity to
succeed it is our fervent request that
our legislators carefully consider the
persistent effects of underfunding our
public schools which rank 50th in the
United States 50th as in last as a proud
New Hampshire citizen this is
embarrassing and
unconscionable the reason you've heard
about it and continue to hear about
about it is it
persists the current system creates
profound inequality forcing towns with
lower property values to make impossible
choices between raising taxes and
cutting essential programs these
disparities Rend the fabric of our great
States communities pitting neighboring
towns against each other these
disparities also discourage young people
from returning to New Hampshire because
only the wealthy can afford to live
where the schools remain properly funded
this is not in the true Spirit of the
Granite
State I'm fortunate to have grown up in
one of the property Rich towns in New
Hampshire and I live currently in one
that is also well
funded I and my board members feel an
obligation and a responsibility to
participate and advocate for those who
cannot advocate for
themselves our state can't afford for
our communities to diminish our economy
and to and need to invest in our state's
future I ask everyone but particularly
the committee members in front of me who
have patiently sat through testimony ask
yourself as you look in the mirror
whether you an elected official of we
the people can turn away from your
neighbors and their families by
continuing to ignore your constitutional
responsibility to fund public education
thank
you Kelsey Brooke Emory and I believe I
have a second card from Damian Santana I
think he spoke and
left okay why did he put in two cards
anyway Kelsey followed by Michelle St
John okay I'm standing in opposition to
further cuts to higher education as it's
related to the state's mandate to
provide an adequate
education um I will not be talking about
my strong opposition to foucher programs
as I agree with most of the already
vocalized concerns the only thing that I
want to add to what has already been
said is a challenge um there is a false
presumption that private schools
outperform public ones and if the
unaccountable voucher program is doing
so well the state needs to publish the
data to prove
that my commentary today is aimed at
connecting the dots between school
budgets low teacher pay declining
teacher programs and cuts to higher
education because they're all connected
my name is Kelsey eert uh I was born
here in conquer raised in Sutton served
the public schools in molteno and I'm a
resident of holderness I'm now the
coordinator of social studies education
at Plymouth State University University
and I'm so proud to see this amazing
group of students over
here I'm also the two-time New Hampshire
history teacher of the year among a
number of other Awards um I now train
the next generation of social studies
teachers at the only College in New
Hampshire with a thriving social studies
education
program our state universities serve our
state at Plymouth it is our motto o
proam that I may serve and foremost um
is the work that we do in creating the
next generation of teachers nurses and
Business
Leaders uh if we continue to take a
for-profit model and apply it to higher
education we will see a degrading effect
across the entire State not just at PSU
we are already seeing these effects UNH
is closing Ed programs Rivier is closing
Ed programs at PSU we were forced to
close early childhood education we've
heard about the effects of that already
today math education Science Education
closed the effect New Hampshire is not
preparing a new generation of math and
science and early childhood Educators we
are importing them or allowing them to
uh we allowing people to bypass higher
education wrongly suggested that any
person who is good at calculus can
somehow convey that to young people
worse while my programs social studies
education is going to survive the budget
cuts that have been proposed by our
president um The Faculty in the content
areas that serve my program like Dr
Lappy might not I cannot provide a
rigorous highquality program with my
Majors by having adjunct faculty member
s serve that program we need people with
doctorates in political science like Dr
Lappy teaching the classes that my
students take and then go on into public
schools to share with other people
minutes if we are serious as a state
about our supposed commitment to high
quality Civics education which is what I
do we need to increase funding to higher
education to support Ed programs by
supporting The Faculty that serve those
programs
okay hi I'm Michelle St John and I'm
here today on behalf of the individuals
and families and staff from Northern
Human Services which serves Coos Carol
and upper Grafton County the stack of
papers that I gave you today are uh
testimonies from individuals who spent
the time um trying to convey but could
not be here in person what I'd like to
ask is if you can indulge me for one
moment while I read some portions from
three of those testimonies it might go a
little bit longer but it is from an
individ ual his parent and his caregiver
time my name is Erica Bickford and I
reside in Center Tuftonboro I have an
adult son who lives with a developmental
disability he's 22 years old and was
diagnosed with an Autism Spectrum
Disorder at the age of three our son
lives at home with my husband our
granddaughter and me he has a part-time
job at Hanford and volun teers at an
equin therapy Barn he plays the guitar
and loves learning about music he's
incredibly kind compassionate and
empathetic he loves people animals and
music at 22 he values his independence
and has given that opportunity in part
thanks to the services he receives
through Northern Human Services Adult
Services Program and his support person
Casey living a meaningful life in our
community means my my son has the
opportunity to engage fully in Social
cultural and recreational activities
while being valued and respected as an
individual for this to happen I cannot
be the one providing his Services a
fulfilling life involves forming
connections with others contributing to
the community and having access to
resources and supports that enhances
one's quality of life for my son this
means being able to work as part of the
service team at Haniford without my
involvement a meaningful life means to
be able to volunteer and give back at
the horse barn forming relationships
with the members of that Community
independently the services and supports
he receives truly Empower him to live as
independently as possible they also
allow my husband and me to avoid the
full-time caregiver role which is
essential for our well-being it is
important for us to continue our work
and maintain a he healthy balance with
our relationship with our son this
balance enables us to lead more
fulfilling lives take care of our mental
health and be the best versions of
ourselves when we are there to support
him should the services he receives
through Adult Services be cut Not only
would his independence be affected but
either my husband or I would have to
leave our jobs to provide full-time care
to keep him as active and and engaged in
his community as he is now and and now
I'd like to briefly just share words
from her son um dear members of the
state finance committee I hope this
letter finds you well I have used chat
gbt to assist me in writing this my name
is you're at three minutes
um would it be possible to share just a
bit of more from Andrew and his
caregiver I'll give you 30
seconds okay so he um Casey his
caregivers made a significant impact on
my life with her assistance I have the
opportunity to volunteer um thanks to
Casey I feel confident happy and safe
she helped me build meaningful
connections allowed me to visit animals
people friends without relying on my mom
without Casey my life would be
drastically different I would feel
isolated sad and even depressed her
presence in my life is a testament to
the importance of continued funding for
Adult Services and I I have just I just
want to strongly encourage that you read
about we we've got another 40 people I
just please read her letter it gives you
the full circle of from the parent to
the individual receiving services and
for the person who is providing that
Services thank you so much I really
you kalayn aank followed by Judith
Jones good afternoon thank you
representative Wier and members of the
committee for the opportunity to speak
today my name is kayin amach and I am
the prevention coordinator for the
Capital Area Public Health Network which
is one of 13 Regional public health
networks that serve New Hampshire the
Capital Area Public Health Network
includes 24 municipalities around
conquer and serves more than
135,000 people as a prevention ordinator
a large part of my work is focused on
preventing substance use disorder and
its related harms throughout the capital
region this work is done through
Community Education and Training
Outreach activities collaboration with
key Community Partners strategic
communication and advocacy efforts I am
here today to strongly support the full
funding of the alcohol fund as proposed
in Governor aot's budget for fiscal
years 26 and 27 the alcohol fund is an
important source of funding for
prevention treat M and Recovery efforts
in the Capital Area and throughout New
Hampshire two important examples of how
the alcohol fund supports our work in
prevention are Student Assistance
Program counselors or saps and the
partnership at drug-free NH Student
Assistance Program counselors are key
staff in our middle and high schools who
are funded through the alcohol fund
their work focuses on preventing youth
substance use through positive
prevention programming and education
they are strong partners for public
health networks as they provide key
insight into school Trends and what is
Meaningful to our students this allows
us to collaborate on prevention
activities that resonate with students
and have a positive impact on their
health
outcomes the partnership at drug free NH
is also funded through the alcohol fund
and is an important source for Effective
Public Health messaging around substance
use and prevention efforts they create
engaging communication toolkits for the
public health networks to utilize during
awareness weeks and months throughout
the year one great example is coming up
next week with national drug and alcohol
fax week their work ensures that we are
communicating accurate effective and
engaging prevention messages within our
communities I hope that some of what
I've shared today has helped illustrate
the importance of the alcohol fund to
New Hampshire's prevention efforts and I
ask that you support its full funding in
the state budget thank you so much for
[Music]
consideration Judith Jones will be
Mayberry good evening chairman and
committee members thank you for the
opportunity to talk a little bit about
healthy Aging in New Hampshire my name
is Judith Jones I'm the policy
coordinator for the New Hampshire
Alliance for healthy aging and here
today to speak on behalf of the New
Hampshire Alliance for healthy aging
which is composed of a number of
individuals and
stakeholders committed to supporting
older adults in the granite state as
they
age in 2023 this body passed Landmark
legislation that adopted the system of
care for healthy aging and this promoted
home and communitybased Care
programs progress under the system of
care for aging must be continued to be
supported building on the existing
infrastructure
so that adults have timely access to
home care including the choices for
Independence program but also other
programs that support community
living as you've heard investing in
programs that enable adults to remain in
the community it's a wise use of
resources given that this support can
delay the need for more costly long-term
care services you've heard other people
speak of the choices for Independence
program specifically about about the
critical need in the community so I
won't go into that in detail but wanted
to highlight a few other key programs
that provide support for folks in the
community and often these programs have
lower dollar figures but can help folks
stay in the community and just a few of
these that you'll see in the budget one
is caregiver respit
programs another is harnessing the power
of senior
volunteers volunteers in the community
help other people in the community
Target the needs of the community
reducing the need for long-term
care we'd also mention Meals on Wheels
congregate housing the need for
Guardianship
Services also the need for access to
public
transportation by providing people
access to Transportation they can get
the support they need for medical care
food
medications and finally just want to say
a word
about the barriers that would be set up
in House Bill 2 regarding accessing
Medicaid and urge you to consider what
that would mean for older adults in New
Hampshire just finally as you draft the
budget you're concerned about cost
Effectiveness keeping individuals in
their homes in New Hampshire is cost
effective it has a high rate of return
and it makes sense for granite Staters
it makes sense for the state budget
Matt Mayberry followed by Amy
te's good afternoon committee my name is
Matt Mayberry I'm the CEO of the New
Hampshire homebuilders Association and
our 27,000 men and women who work in the
Residential Building Trades and I'm here
to give you
money I don't want it I want to give it
to
you because I bring you Solutions and
cash to conquer our housing challenges
in your budget you'll see administrative
charges uh from do and Dees to expedite
and augment the residential building
permit
process the New Hampshire Home Builders
have offered and we have asked for these
charges currently a driveway permit can
take up to 18 months if you support our
public private initiative we can get
that process down to
6060 business
days we have asked for more permitting
personnel and we the Builders of New
Hampshire are willing to pay for
it and I hate when I lose my
place time is money but time is money
but time is also not our friend the New
Hampshire Home Builders and state
agencies have charted a new and
effective path forward now we're asking
our legislative leaders to give us a
green light and most respectfully
afterwards get out of the way we know
what to
do as an industry we have heard you and
we're offering an additional solution to
our state's number one economic
you have you given us the text
Matt no sir but I can thank you and I'll
also expand a little bit about what
those permits do so just try respectful
your time thank you thank you Amy te's
will be followed by Ken
Gordon hi thank you um I'm here to say
to ask please fund services for
developmental disabilities and acquired
brain disorders um they are our beloved
Sons and Daughters um I'm going to talk
to you about early Support
Services uh my name is Amy wheeler tees
I am a native Granite stator and I live
in nashwa I am the mom of three
extraordinary married children two of
which were born with a rare genetic
syndrome called
sodos our son Frankie who is a humorous
affectionate 10-year-old um began
receiving early intervention services
through early supports at gateways when
he was 5 months old he continued to get
physical and speech therapy until he was
three and then he was transitioned at 3
years old to intensive needs special
education um at the Nashville School
District the impact that that early
support that he received from zero to
three
um wasn't really fully realized until we
adopted our third child um we adopted
our daughter magdalina in 2021 from an
orphanage in Bulgaria and she was born
with the same rare genetic disorder
sodos um but she had spent her first 5
and a half years of life in a Bulgarian
orphanage so she did not get early
support
services and it was staggering to us to
see the difference between she and our
son by birth um now granted not all
people with sodos are going to be
identical but um my house is a is a home
study to prove like here's a child with
the same genetic disorder that was born
the same year as child who who didn't
get the early support services
so um I'm here to impress upon you a
real life example of why funding these
types of programs matters because I have
seen the difference and it's not lost on
me that it's a tremendous blessing what
we have in New Hampshire that people
around the world don't so please do the
right thing please fund um programs that
support developmental
disabilities um protect their most
vulnerable Frankie and magdalina are
counting on you thank
[Applause]
you Ken Gordon followed by jwes
gourd chairman Wier members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify today my name is Ken Gordon I
serve as the CEO of Coos County family
health services we're a federally
qualified Health Center with offices in
colbrook Berlin and
gorum we provide Primary Care Dental
Services Behavioral Health Services
substance abuse
Services uh for 13,000 people and uh do
that at five clinical sites and two
dental clinics we o provide care for
more than 200 people living in nursing
homes in our
area we are deeply concerned about the
proposed cuts to the State Medicaid
Program and the granite Advantage
Program to be clear these Cuts
jeopardize the health and well-being of
every citizen in New Hampshire not just
those who are participants in this
program they do so by threatening to
unravel the financial underpinnings of
our state's Health Care System nearly
every component of the Health Care
system that we know today is dependent
upon Medicaid from our local ambulance
services to primary care clinics to home
care services to hospitals to nursing
homes these systems are already under
stress additional Financial losses
resulting from Medicaid Cuts will
undermine the very existence of some of
them in my view it's not an exaggeration
to suggest that we may lose some of
these critical Services if these cuts
and others being proposed at the federal
level take place for people who rely on
these programs they will feel it most
strongly but all of us will feel it and
will feel it in various forms those
forms include local ambulance services
that are no longer available delays in
access to Primary Care and Specialty
Care longer wait times in emergency
departments delayed Hospital admissions
decreased availab ility of nursing home
beds and importantly insurance premium
increases for those With Private health
insurance we understand the serious
Financial uh burden upon the state and
the extraordinary dilemma that you all
face as you craft a budget this year we
ask that you prioritize the health and
well-being of the state's residents
above other needs and that you preserve
current funding levels for the state's
Medicaid and granted granted Advantage
healthc Care programs thank you up for
consideration all right juwels I it's
Hampshire person's no no longer
thank you and she will be followed by
Karen
smooch good evening my name is Kate
fryan the vice president of advocacy at
new fatures we appreciate the
opportunity to testify on House Bill one
house bill two and the governor's budget
proposal and the committee's time this
evening uh new Futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that works to
improve the health and wellness of all
New Hampshire residents we follow
several areas within the Department of
Health and Human Services budget but
I'll just highlight a few you heard a
little bit about the alcohol fund the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs the um new features has
always supported a fully funded alcohol
fund um the intent behind this is the
alcohol fund would be funded by 5% of
gross profits of substantial sale of
alcohol revenues um up until uh the last
budget cycle it was always it was never
fully funded or it was diverted it was
this committee that restored that
funding um since then the governor's
commission has made substantial
commitments to the state substance use
disorder infrastructure not only did you
hear about the student assistant
programs prevention C uh coordinators
but I have with me today um dozens of
letters from recovery centers and
treatment centers that have been able to
do the work under the alcohol fund as
well as their annual report we also
support the system for children's
Behavioral Health healthare within the
division of Behavioral Health Services
it's important to fully fund the
children's system of care we are
concerned about a um a cut that may not
allow the children's system of Care
Resource Center to continue um we've
made a lot of Headway in the children's
system of care and we really feel it's
important to um fully fund these
critical Services there are various
areas within the division of Public
Health Services uh that we um want to
see funded for moms babies and young
children this is childhood Le prevention
Community collaboration Grant home
visiting Grant um which provides home
visiting and Family Resource
Centers lastly just to touch base on
what you heard about the graned
advantage premiums we have concerns
about what that impact will be to
clients um we know that charging
premiums will lead to substantial
disenrollment it will also um not really
generate the potential Revenue gains
we're uh concerned about the offset that
other um hospitals and providers will
see and um we also are concerned about
people using more expensive um Services
if they are disenrolled it will bring
unintended additional costs to the state
for that reason um we are we would like
the legislature to reconc reconsider
premiums and cost sharing I also have
testimony from someone who had to leave
Julie jurus and I will hand it in as
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee I appreciate the time and
the privilege of speaking with you today
I am Karen shuck I am here representing
Amis Health as one of its board members
and also as the Chief Human Resources
officer of Catholic Charities
representing healthc care for the
homeless I will add to Ken Gordon's
comments by simply saying that at amamos
they serve 60,000 adults that Medicaid
is thear largest source of their patient
Revenue with 57% medical and 61% of
their Mental Health visits being covered
in the last fiscal year 76% of these
individuals are below 200% of the
federal poverty level health care for
the homeless cares for an additional
1,00 individuals in the Manchester area
49% of which are are supported by
Medicaid 95% of these individuals live
below 200% of the federal poverty level
kend did a great job already of
illustrating the impact of what happens
if we look at one portion of our Health
Care system and don't look at it in a
sort of well-rounded view um and and
looking at these two particular
organizations being at sort of that
first layer if you will of immediate
impact to Residents to their families in
the community in Manchester you heard
about the North Country um same applies
for what Ken had to say but more for the
southern part of the state the ripples
that we would experience if these Cuts
were made um would create the same kinds
of ripples that he talked about um
including placements for rehabilitation
long-term care emergency rooms and
hospitals I appreciate your time thanks
very
much next Christine Stoddard followed by
good evening my name is Christine
Stoddard and I represent by state
Primary Care Association and New
Hampshire's community health centers
they serve over a 100,000 people and as
you've heard from two earlier speakers
most of their patients live at 200% of
the federal poverty level or below
that's about
$30,000 the health centers take all
patients regardless of their ability to
pay or Insurance status they cannot turn
patients away if they lose their
insurance if there were changes made to
the Medicaid Program in the state of New
Hampshire we have studies that show that
the health centers would increase their
uncompensated Care by about $35 million
there's only 10 of them that's a lot of
uncompensated care for 10 organizations
to absorb in 2023 even with granted
Advantage they had $14.5 million of
uncompensated care our safety net system
can cannot afford for the legislature to
reduce Medicaid Eligibility at this
point if you remember back before we had
Medicaid expansion what the substance
use disorder treatment Network looked
like it was non-existent and it is
because of granted advantage that our
residents in New Hampshire have access
to substance use disorder treatment what
will they do if they can't access
treatment where will they go the fqhcs
would have to shut down their services
just to give you a recent example one of
our health centers had to stop providing
as much mat because Medicaid medicated
medicated assisted treatment because the
reimbursement for mat is substantially
lower than primary care that's not the
outcome that we want to have but that's
a reality as a business that they face
we ask that you please not reduce the
Medicaid ibility for any of the Medicaid
programs thank
[Applause]
you David let's see Christine stod just
spoke right yes sir David Trumble
followed by Holly
Stevens thank you Mr chairman and
committee members for for your patience
and listening uh my name is David
Trumble I'm from the town of wear I'd
like to bring a few points for your
consideration first is New Hampshire is
ranked 48th in the United States for our
state economy we have one of the three
worst economies in the entire country
that's from the CNBC annual ranking of
the states why are we so bad it's
because we don't invest in our people
they specifically cited housing and
child care in their stud
we can't fix the housing crisis through
regulatory reform alone it's going to
require funding to make the housing
Supply go up it's going to require
funding to make it more affordable and
we have to have a real solution to the
homelessness crisis homelessness went up
over 40% this past year alone and to not
do anything about that is unconscionable
also they talked about child care we
need to have more people we you heard
about training and retention we need
bigger Longer hours so families can
access child care and we need to expand
the scholarship program that means
changing our mindset as a state from
every dollar we spend being a dollar
that's gone to being a dollar that we
invest in our people I'd like to turn to
Public Schools I'll try and say
something different from previous
speakers education research shows that
funding Public Schools it pays it
increases lifetime earnings it decreases
adult poverty Professor Jackson from
Northwestern University University is a
expert in the field who's looked at
dozens of studies he says that a 10%
increase in per pupil spending can
result in a 99.5% increase in earnings
that's lifetime a 6.8% reduction in
adult poverty that's 10% so if you have
a town that's not funding a lot let's
say 15,000 per pupil if you give them
1,500 more you take a lot of people out
of poverty you reverse that cycle of
poverty you lift that town up he goes on
to say that a 25% increase is
sufficiently large to eliminate the
attainment gaps between children from
low and high income families so for a
few thousand dollar you can make every
town in this state have good schools
next is special education the governor's
got a lot of positive praise for
increasing special ed funding but in the
big picture think about a pizzapi the
state share is going from
11% to 12% the local towns are still
going to be paying 81% instead of 82% it
barely budges the needle it is your job
constitutionally to fend fund all of
that not 11% or 12% lastly is where do
you get the money from New Hampshire's
tax system is highly regressive The
Institute on tax and economic policy
shows that low-income people in the
state pay three times as much as a
percentage of their income as wealthy
people and if you put that 5% income tax
the Medicaid payments they'll be paying
14% of their income in taxes in the
state while the wealthy get away with
paying 3 or 4% the question you should
be asking yourself is what does a fair
tax system look like how can we raise
this tax system which is so regressive
right now and have it be a little more
balanced so that everybody can get the
services that they need so that we
invest in our state and our tax system
you in my pile I can't across Julie urks
who had a note need to leave at 3:00 has
she
left all right sorry I didn't see the
notes
soon all right next is Holly Stevens who
chairman wer and members of the finance
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify today my name is Holly
Stevens and I am the director of Public
public policy at Nami New Hampshire the
National Alliance on Mental Illness on
behalf of Nami New Hampshire I offer the
following testimony in addition to our
written testimony I am providing you
with some written testimony of two of
our members um along with
my my testimony for years New Hampshire
has been facing a mental health crisis
one in five adults and one in five youth
age 6 to 17 experience a mental illness
each year in New Hampshire that's 20% of
our population aged six
to 90 100 um experience a mental health
issue every single year the most visible
symptom of this crisis is emergency room
boarding of individuals in Mental Health
crisis while waiting for an impatient
bed yesterday 31 adults and three
children were waiting for a psychiatric
impatient admission at a New Hampshire
ER somewhere in the state and I just
checked the numbers as I was sitting
here and now it is 35 adults and five
children that are waiting
today the mission zero initiative has
helped address the ER boarding crisis
however despite the steady progress of
the initiative more needs to be done to
ensure we're able to get to zero and
stay at
zero a couple of the root causes of the
Mental Health crisis that you've heard
about today so I won't get into a lot
are the workforce issue and the housing
crisis that we're um facing both
Workforce housing and additionally we
need Supportive Housing including step
up and step down units to support folks
with mental illness who are unable to
live alone on any any given day there
are 50 to 60 people ready to leave New
Hampshire hospital but are not able to
do so because they have no place to go
having Supportive Housing would assist
addressing this backdoor issue so that
we can get people out of the ER and into
psychiatric placements that they so
desperately need additionally robust
investments in Community Resources such
as the children's system of care 988 in
the crisis service system intensive
reent re-entry services Community Mental
Health Centers and the goals of the 10
mental 10-year Mental Health Plan are
essential to supporting people in our
communities in avoiding crisis and I
know you have heard about it a couple of
times but I would be remiss if I did not
mention that um the proposed changes to
Med to the Medicaid Program that include
instituting premiums on certain
beneficiaries and increasing co-payments
for medications would be detrimental to
New Hampshire's uh citizen
the changes suggested will only lead to
decreases in coverage for both adults
and children interruptions in treatment
increases in health care costs and
worsening of the Mental Health crisis in
summary it's imperative that house
finance builds a budget that fully
addresses the Mental Health crisis we
are currently in and uses Extreme
Caution when considering changes to the
Medicaid Program that include increased
cost sharing for our beneficiaries thank
you very much for your time
[Applause]
Robert Gillis to be followed by Sandra
May nice
job I guess I can say good evening
chairman wher and committee members um
thank you for your time this evening U
my name is Robert Gillis my wife Noel
and I live in Hancock New Hampshire um
and I'm the executive director for manad
Work Source a small not for profit that
for 54 years has been delivering
disability service to our community
members who experience Developmental and
intellectual disabilities um I've been
very proud to live in the state of New
Hampshire that was the first state in
the nation to close its institutional
delivery system of care for disabled
adults when they closed the Leonia state
school now is not the time for us to go
backwards one of the folks from my
agency that joined me earlier today um
spent her formative youth at lonia state
school and endured deplorable conditions
and substandard care thanks to New
Hampshire's leadership in
community-based services for adults with
disabilities she now lives in her own
apartment she has her own name on the
lease she has her own paintings on the
wall and she lives the life that anyone
of our New Hampshire residents deserve
to live in our fine State um I applaud
governor aat for at least submitting a
maintenance budget to keep disability s
funding similar to what it was last year
um but it truly is not enough but we'll
take what we can get um we've heard a
lot of stories today so I won't tell any
more but for me as an executive director
I need a Workforce and I can't deliver
the services that were funded for
without employees and so please pass hb1
and hb2 but also please consider any
efforts that are put before the
legislature for increasing funding for
Workforce especially for care of our
most vulnerable populations thank you
time Sandra May followed by Chris MC
McCracken Chris
McCracken good afternoon chairman wiler
and honored committee members my name is
Sandra May and I'm a resident of Haner
where I'm happy to support that I'm
happy to report that we increased our
voter turnout in yesterday's election by
50% um I'm speaking to you this evening
to express my concern about house bill
to I see the governor's budget is
placing a lot of faith in the growth of
New Hampshire business and while I
certainly hope she's right the headlines
that I see in the national news suggest
many coming headwinds over which we have
little or no State Control regarding the
spending choices before us I'm delighted
as the granddaughter of a Philadelphia
detective that um you're uh committing
to uh renewing your uh provision for a
secure requirement for our retirement
for our police
force but I'm here also as a small
business person um creating housing in
the state um asking you to make strong
and well-educated Workforce a priority
as well further expanding the
educational Freedom account program to
families who already made the choice to
enroll their children in private school
siphons off money from our painfully
High property taxes to people who are
not struggling at all we keep saying our
Workforce is graying and we want young
people to stay here or move here what
kind of message are we sending when we
continue to ignore our own Court's
finding on adate
education sorry if you want your child
to have a good education either one of
you has to give up your career and stay
home and home school or one of you has
to take a second job to find the rest of
the money for private school where are
we going to find the future trades
people that we need to build our housing
is it going to be that private school
student who yearbook committee voted
them most likely to take on Wall Street
by storm or is it going to be that kid
that made sure that they got the grades
to win one of the few seats on the bus
to conquered Regional Tech the EFA
program has already been demonstrated to
cost far more than expected please in
these uncertain times don't explode that
funding to benefit the wealthy at the
expense of our Workforce please remove
this expansion from the budget thank
thank you all for your
[Applause]
time okay that was Chris mccan McCracken
here how about
Jonathan
uh my name is Jonathan field with the
Colonia housing and Home Health agency
uh we were in our small Home Health
agency with under 15 employees in lonia
I'm here to speak about the importance
of appropriate funding for home and
communitybased services that are
essential for those we serve and is most
financially responsible uh for
investment by the state uh over the last
budget cycle State funding has allowed
us to make a meaningful impact the
congregate housing service progam
program chsp which is funded through
General funds enabled us to serve 36
additional individuals providing 3600
additional hours of care allowing
vulnerable individuals to remain safely
home safely at home prevented at least
three individuals from requiring nursing
home care saving approximately
$210,000 for the State uh verted at
least seven ER visits and Hospital
admissions saving around
$56,000 provided a crucial safety net
for those who lost CFI eligibility or
needed a bridge while waiting for
determinations the choices for
Independence program CFI allowed us to
serve 47 individuals ensuring they could
remain in their homes rather than enter
in institutional care reduce Reliance on
Emergency Medical Service Services which
is facing an unprecedented burden in our
area saving an average of $1,100 per
call uh prevent ER visits and admissions
saving 7 to $10,000 per stay reducing
nursing Home Care saving approximately
person additionally both programs have
helped keep individuals independently
housed and prevent uh prevented
evictions which translates into
significant cost savings for the state
particularly among those in subsidized
housing by helping maintain clean and
safe Living Spaces as enforced by hug
HUD regulations evictions cost the
public $2 to $5,000 in court costs and
legal expenses who publicly f programs
like nhla many have no other housing
options once evicted they face a high
risk of homelessness or institutional
placement both of which have far greater
Financial consequences for the state
homelessness costs an estimated $30,000
per person nursing home care as
mentioned costs around $70,000 per
person to maintain these vital programs
we request the continuation of the chsp
fund funding through General funds at
approximately $400,000 per provider this
program has been removed from the budget
it is set to end in June of this year
leaving 27 plus individuals without care
we are only one of two providers in New
Hampshire offering chsp Services
alongside Manchester housing authority
this program provides at least a 2:1
return on
investments realistically closer to 4:1
I gave a conservative estimate on the
cost of a nursing home care um by
preventing homelessness and higher cost
interventions we request an increase in
Billing code
h43 suppor of Housing Services Under CFI
we are the only provider in the state
currently providing Services Under this
billing code this uh this rate is not
inj adjusted in the last round of CFI
increases leaving us at risk of being
unable to continue offering this
critical
Service uh I thank you for listening to
me and um again these
initiatives uh provide safe and
affordable housing and Home Health
Services thank you thank you Mr field we
Dei neither one
you uh followed by Brian
Hawkins good evening Mr chairman and uh
members uh my name is Ethan Sylvio dup
and I am a junior double major ATL of
political science and history at pman
State University uh for transparency I
am a student voting member of the
University system New Hampshire Board of
Trustees uh but I'm purely going to be
speaking on behalf of being a
student um let's see oh uh I am both
president of Puma State University
College Republicans and I'm also the
vice chairman of the New Hampshire
Federation for college Republicans uh I
just wanted to make my kind of testimony
heard that I've never felt any
alienation from my professors uh based
off my conservative beliefs and trust me
they've had every opportunity to do so
because I've had two public debates and
I've very much fiercely defended my
conservative values um I am speaking
today uh on the $16 million cut to the
university system uh which has placed
both of my majors in Jeopardy uh may I
say I love our great state and our way
of life I am born and Brad in New
Hampshire and I'm so proud to be
standing in the capital the free estate
in the
country that being said since I love my
state I want people to stay in my state
and continue to grow our
state um therefore I believe the state
should fund and invest our universities
PSU is the lifeline uh for educated
Workforce in the North country as
students fall in love with the northern
part of the of the state and wish to
stay in New Hampshire for jobs and a
wonderful way of
life I believe that placing more funding
into our universities will promote the
student revenue and uh potential
taxpaying residents for the State of New
you Brian Hawkins followed by Christine
uh
lechance thank you Mr chairman for the
record Brian Hawkins representing Nea
New Hampshire we represent thousands of
uh Public School Educators across the
state um I'll boil try and boil my
testimony down from what has already
been said but first I'd like to say the
there's a cautionary tale out there from
all the states that have expanded um
their voucher programs and you have
heard a lot of very important needs from
the people in this audience today and so
one of the things that we know in in
education from those States who have
expanded those programs
significantly is that uh the effort to
fund Public Schools uh for who serve the
significant majority of our students has
declined in those States um Arizona
obviously is a great example now costing
over a billion dollars a year since they
have thrown the doors open on that
program our program as it is already
just under current law would be $41
million per year by the time uh we hit
FY 27 we also know that uh in places
like Arizona Florida consistent ly um
those the people who are using those
were already in private schools or other
settings and were on the wealthier end
of the spectrum um in some schools in
Florida you're talking about 98% of
those counties where in private schools
are using uh Florida vouchers um so uh
I'll just close by
saying uh you've heard a lot of needs um
tonight
and why would
we uh send vouchers for kids who are
coming from
homes that are uh for
millionaires we don't need to do that
you've heard a lot of the fun the needs
that we have today um whether it's Child
Care public education Health Care um
those are the things that we ought to be
emphasizing not vouchers for people who
are uh make million dollars a year thank
you very much thank
Blake oh she's not here okay thank you
followed by uh Christina kth I guess go
ahead good good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee I'm Christina
lechance I'm from gilmington I'm the
interim director at New Hampshire
children's trust and a member of the
wellness and primary prevention Council
for new
Hampshire at New Hampshire trust our
mission is to strengthen families by
empowering parents and caregivers
through education advocacy collaboration
and investment we work to build more
supportive communities and Foster
healthy relationships that positively
impact Children and Families across the
granite state the children's trust is
the state chapter of prevent child abuse
America and focuses on prevention
ensuring families are strong and
supported long before challenges arise
thank you for the opportunity to provide
testimony and support of Family Resource
Centers child care for working parents
and assistance for childcare workers
these programs are critical in fostering
resilience self-sufficiency and parent
success across the granite state since
2020 the trust has served as a
facilitating organization supporting New
Hampshire's expansive network of Family
Resource Centers as such I'll spend the
majority of my time sharing their story
The Incredible Family Resource Centers
we support are squarely focused on
families they are serving with programs
aimed at resilience self-sufficiency and
parent success the numbers speak for
themselves since 2020 over 27,000 New
Hampshire residents have been supported
through Family Resource Centers in local
communities as we sit here today 7,000
children and families are actively
receiving support at their local Family
Resource Center the work of the family
Resource Centers is expansive families
from 257 cities and towns or 99% of New
Hampshire's communities have benefited
from F FRC Services the effectiveness of
these programs is best illustrated by a
story quickly I have two quotes from
families one parent reported to us the
family worker at my FRC was amazingly
helpful I will never forget her nor will
my children she helped us through an
extraordinary
extraordinarily difficult time and
another family said I'm a 48-year-old
raising two toddlers And this program
has changed my life I have grown as a
person and gained strength I never
thought I had these stories reinforce
the necessity of sustaining support for
f frc's as identified in the proposed
budget in addition to expressing our
support for Family Resource Centers I'd
like to take a moment and share the
quality stable Child Care supports
healthy child development Workforce
participation and economic growth we
support hb2 section 112 allowing DHHS to
allocate additional funds to prevent
weightless for child care so their
parents can go to work I won't read
through the rest of my testimony here
which states the uh need to reduce
burdens on the childcare community
as well as parents last I urge you to
extend the $1 million Workforce
assistance project funds which have only
just begun to move to help Child Care
Staffing thank you so much for your time
today investing in Family Resource
Centers Child Care scholarship expansion
our child care Workforce will strengthen
the economy strengthen families and our
communities we urge full funding and
policy improvements for this important
work thank you again for your time have
some dinner thank
you all right we have Christine and
Jennifer
done followed by uh Kristen
Evans hi my name is Christine KY I live
in marac with my big brother s and Jen
my sister and law I love going to Camp
Allen for sleep away camp and day camp
for my
birthday I also like horse riding at
upreach every Mondays Jen asked me to
share how I would feel if I couldn't go
my
activities I would be very mad
frustrated angry and upset
if I could not go to these places to
have fun and be with all my friends I
asking you to fully fund the re
Recreation services Fund in the next
budget so that I can continue being with
my friends and have fun thank you thank
you
all right Jennifer cloy thank
you uh I was going to say good afternoon
but good evening uh chairman and members
of the finance committee my name is
Jennifer kudi and I live in marac with
Christine I'm here to request increased
funding for the Bureau of Developmental
services to attract qualified direct
support professionals or dsps and respit
care providers two years ago after my
mother-in-law passed away my husband and
I became guardians of Christine who was
intellectually disabled I was excited to
get her re-engaged in the community but
quickly discovered a critical shortage
of dsps stories of neglect like dsps
taking Christine to their home to nap
showed how vital it is to have caring
professional support this is something
that we do not want Christine to
experience again or anybody else to
ensure Christine's progress I had to
leave my 17-year career as a par
educator to become her full-time care
initially I thought this was temporary
but the lack of staffing has made me her
best and at this point only option as a
small business owner I am torn between
giving Christine what she needs and what
she deserves and what our business needs
to be able to be successful so we may
continue to provide things for Christine
Christine thrives in activities like
horseback riding Special Olympics
basketball and her classes at Community
integrated services in Manchester but
without more funding to to attract and
retain dsps I worry about her future who
will care for her when I am no longer
able will my daughter have to sacrifice
her career in order to step in I urge
you to prioritize funding for dsps so
families like mine and others that were
here um do not have to give up
everything to ensure that our loved ones
receive the care they need and deserve I
thank you for your time this evening in
listening to my story thank you thank
you
kak chairman members of the committee
for the record my name is Kristen Evans
and I am the director of policy for AEL
New Hampshire Abel is a disability
Justice organization and we fight for
the civil and human rights of people
with disabilities in New Hampshire let
me be absolutely clear this proposal to
impose premiums on Medicaid is not just
acceptable it is
cruel it is an attack on the very people
our government is supposed to protect
Medicaid is not a handout it is not a
luxury it is survival it keeps people
with disabilities in their homes in
their communities and out of Crisis it
is the difference between dignity and
despair and between life and death and
yet this committee is actually
considering forcing the poorest sickest
and most vulnerable among us to pay for
the care they need just to stay
alive let's call this what it is
balancing the budget on the backs of
people who have nowhere else to
turn the people who rely on Medicaid
already navigate a world full of
barriers they fight every single day
just to access basic health care to find
housing to work against a system that is
never built for them and now you want to
make them fight harder to force
impossible choices between rent food and
life-saving care I urge you drop this
plan do not be the legislators who chose
bureaucracy over Humanity do not be the
ones who decided that saving a few
dollars mattered more than the lives of
real people do better because this is
shameful thank you
[Applause]
Frank kak followed by lmiller
jaka
Hampshire James Kelly from
conquer all of the people just mentioned
were sitting here they left due to other
wait Jane
win and is Lynn wette here not no she's
she's
not how about Amy
next so funny winner winner chicken
dinner
right good
evening chairman Wier and members of the
house finance committee for the record
my name is Jane Marquee I am a native
nashin and have been the director of
child care at the Nashville Adult
Learning Center for 32 years we
currently serve serve 72 young children
ages 6 weeks to 6 years with their
families and they all come from varied
socioeconomic and Multicultural
backgrounds as a nonprofit child care
provider I am here today to tell you
about the important impact the recent
Workforce grant that we received in
August has had on our community-based
highquality Child Care Program the
workforce Grant received in August has
increased our ability to recruit and
retain qualified Child Care teachers
helping to maintain our child care
program's ability to serve our community
some of the actual results that this
Workforce Grant gave us were low teacher
turnover experienced and educated and
enthused teachers our own agency's
investment in teachers through wage
increases and an unprecedented bonus
award I am very concerned that without
the restoration of the $15 million in
the state budget to retain and recruit
to recruit and retain rather um
qualified teachers could force our
program to revert to struggling in those
areas this would cause our child care
program's ability to serve our community
to weaken and decrease
significantly I thank you for listening
and for your consideration of childcare
Workforce Recruitment and Retention in
you all right Amy Upton will be followed
by is Blake mosman
here
Carrie
durin
wolfboro is she
next good evening my name is Amy Upton
and I'm I reside in bone New Hampshire
and I'm here to talk to you about what
I've been doing for the last 41 years
and that is providing Child Care I've
been a childcare director in conquered
for 35 years I opened the program 35
years ago with six children and I'm
still there and now well there's 100 we
are licensed for 185 there's a lot more
than that that we serve and uh over
those years I was trying to figure out
how much my salary has changed and it's
um a little bit too embarrassing to tell
you and although it's been tiresome to
wait here to talk to you um the good
news is that I am not tired of providing
Child Care I've been doing it for a long
time and I am so thankful for the
opportunity I look forward to Monday as
much as I work forward to Friday as I
look forward to Saturday and it is
mindboggling to me that we would have
the amount of money that we've had for
the childcare Workforce 15 million to go
from that to go to zero and I am
imploring you to please
continue providing money for the
childcare Workforce just as I'm going to
continue providing care for the children
and families of conquered in the
outlying areas um throughout the years I
have gone from when I opened my program
I had an associates degree I have a
master's degree now my pay hasn't
changed that much from when I had an
associates degree to a master's degree
and the reason why I got that degree was
not necessarily to gain more knowledge
which I certainly did um I've also
taught at UNH at uh Plymouth State and
20 years at nhti in conquer but the
reason why I taught was I didn't have
enough money to put my own children
through college because of the amount of
money that I made as a childcare worker
so I taught College until my children
were done going through college and
happy to say that they are all grown and
um serving our state of New Hampshire
two of them so uh it's it's an important
field like you've heard already from
many of my colleagues and from the CPA
that works at my program
that took a huge job a huge pay cut to
come and serve at East Side Learning
Center and if that didn't happen after
35 years my program probably wouldn't be
existing because I am very good at
managing children and managing staff I
am not very good at managing money or
knowing how to go out there and get it
and I'm thankful that I have somebody
that does know how to do that as you've
heard a letter went out to our families
um I think we've had over probably in
the last week 150 emails of how how
upset and distraught parents are that we
raised our rates it was not that much
and the only reason they were raised at
all is because I had a CPA that could
figure out how much money we had to have
to continue to pay our staff the amount
of money that they are making right now
and still be able which we were able to
do and give them slight raises due to
the childware workforce Grant which now
um we we don't have any you know we
don't suddenly we can't go back and pay
them less money so just to maintain our
our staff that we have um the rates have
had to increase for families and
numerous changes made such as our
availability for how much time we can
offer due to Staffing so please continue
providing money for the childcare
Workforce so childcare workers can
you okay and I guess I got an that was
was that carry I'm carry you're Carrie
all right and Aaron also answered is
that correct all right you're
next good
evening thank you chairman and members
of the committee for the opportunity to
speak today long long day and um I
really appreciate your time my name is
Carrie Duran I live in wolfboro New
Hampshire I am the legislative liaison
for Lakes Region Community Services we
serve those with developmental
disabilities hence the pink lots of pink
today lots of support for developmental
services but but I'm here today to
testify as a mom I'm a single mom of
three girls I have 18-year-old twin
girls who one is a freshman at Plymouth
one is a freshman at UNH and I have a
13-year-old daughter almost 14 next week
who was born with a developmental
disability of down syndrome and I was
really hoping she was going to be able
to be here today if she was she would
have shared with you her love of High
School Musical and she would tell you
all about her dreams and plans of going
to college at the UNH for you program
and what I would like to say as a mom is
thank you thank you to always fully
supporting developmental Disability
Services thank you for supporting early
supports and services so my daughter
Katie could have the support she needed
for speech therapy occupational therapy
physical therapy to be able to read at
grade level have beautiful penmanship
and have all of these Big Dreams because
she got the supports that she needed
because she is in the inhome supports
waiver program Medicaid waiver program
she has the supports that she needs in
our home to continue to thrive she has
the supports currently within our school
district with a pair of professional to
be able to thrive at school of course
I'm concerned as a parent about special
education I am also very concerned about
Medicaid being a recipient of Medicaid
um myself and the expanded Medicaid
Program and my three girls I want to say
thank you for fully funding Medicaid not
imposing premiums as a single mom of
three there is no way I could have
afforded uh to take care of myself if I
had to pay for those premiums so I want
to say thank you thank you for being
able to help a mom like me in all of
these years for the first time I am
working full-time since before I had
kids I have not been able to had a have
a full-time job since I became pregnant
um 19 years ago because I was a single
parent I was lower income I live in
subsidized housing uh Workforce housing
and I had a child with special needs to
take care of but thank you because of
all the services the state of New
Hampshire has provided a family like
mine we are successful and I want to
make sure that other families are
successful um so I for you please fully
fund DD Services Medicaid and thank you
again so much for your time it was a
pleasure to be here today thank you
thank
you all right Aaron
arsk excuse me how about is Liz everyone
Jennifer Belmont I'm here all right
you'll be next after Aaron thank you yes
uh esteemed members of the house finance
committee thank you for still being
awake and alert um I've come here to
respectfully suggest that you Recons the
proposed budget especially with regards
to steep Cuts in the Department of
Health and Human Services the Department
of Behavioral Health and the Department
of Child Protection uh taking a machete
to these already underfunded Apartments
will leave them lifeless and ineffective
as I understand it the overall budget
will increase R roughly 1% this year
with the largest decreases of about 25
to 30% among the A4 mentioned agencies
the very agencies that are most
necessary to protect disabled children
and adults the most vulnerable people in
our society I'm here to explain why
these proposed Cuts would be a terrible
idea and cause children and their
families to suffer and even die if you
don't believe me you'll have to enter
into my world one of my two boys has
autism and a sleep did when my wife when
my son uh my disabled son lived at home
I would have to tag team with my wife to
stay up awake all night to make sure
that he didn't flood the house or burn
it down or egress and wander through the
neighborhood uh where he was at risk of
being hit by a car or freezing to death
he didn't have the capacity to navigate
the world it meant locking all the doors
at night and uh turning off the
microwave and the water man and
unplugging the appliances um just so we
could get through in the evening or end
the night uh we did this while trying to
raise our our Second neurotypical Son as
best as we could while going to our
full-time jobs uh this lifestyle was not
sustainable and it required me to drink
vast quantities of coffee and uh eat at
every opportunity just to stay awake so
that I could I could parent um I became
clinically obese pre-diabetic I took
five pills from my heart three blood
pressure medications uh my doctor told
me I had to change this I was on my way
to disability and death uh and I did
change
uh my son got access to the appropriate
programs and it changed all this uh so
all four of us could live and even
Thrive so today I stand before you alive
I'm alive because my son has a Medicaid
funding I'm alive because my son's
funding page for the necessary around
the- clock services that it takes for
him to be safe I'm rested and productive
and healthy and my wife and son are
productive members of the society like
Loaves and Fishes every dollar spent on
my son's Medicaid and behavioral program
and protective services created health
and wellness for myself my family my son
the community and Beyond New Hampshire
even there is truly a multiplier effect
on health and wellness from disability
funding a trickle down effect so great
that it would make Ronald Reagan blush
if May Rest In Peace So I respectfully
suggest members of the House reject the
Steep Cuts in the budget aimed at the
Department of Health and Human Services
Behavioral Health and Child Protection
these cuts are fiscally IR irresponsible
and a bad idea and in my opinion they're
thanks okay before I call on Jennifer is
Courtney spaldin Spalding mayor
here how
Sears
Olivia
harik you'll NE you're next after
you Jennifer thank you thank you
chairman Wier and house finance
committee my name is Jennifer Belmont
Earl I live in barington with my husband
and are two beautiful autistic boys aged
eight and
five I object to the number 63 part of
hb2 which directs the proceeds of the
sale of the former Laconia State School
campus property to be applied to the
subsequent land Building and
improvements at one Granite place the
lonia state school is not a property
like any other the site of the
dehumanization of several generations of
people with developmental disabilities
some of whose bones are buried there in
unmarked Graves before 1940 and when
they dig it dig it up to develop it they
will find
them these people deserve to be
remembered and I think some of the
proceeds from the sale of the in the
property should go towards
that my Aunt Kathy was born in 1953 in
Portsmouth um and she had um what today
is developmental disabilities um and
back then was called mental retardation
and the first thing the doctor said to
my grandma was do not send her to
Laconia so they didn't they my
grandparents Betty and Joe Belmont
became disability activists in
Portsmouth with great bay services or
Ark back then and my Aunt Kathy held my
boys when they were
born my grandpa was one of several
concerned parents that superintendent
Richard Hungerford snuck into Laconia to
film The horrendous living conditions
that people were forced to endure in the
1950s it's in the documentary lost in
lonia if you haven't seen it these
activists hoped that the film they
captured would compel the New Hampshire
State Legislature which passed
legislation establishing theonia State
School in 1901 to act they did not lonia
was officially closed in 1991 after the
landmark case gity v Galan
when it closed its former residents
moved out into the community and
received amazing services and in many
cases lived in group homes one of these
people was Nelly a gentle and kind woman
who was friends with my Aunt Kathy and
lived at Great Bay she spent most of her
life at lonia and said they were never
allowed to go swimming even though the
Laconia State School overlooked the
water yep she didn't know how to use a
fork and knife until she came out of
there
I think that the people that survived
Laconia should have a say in what some
of the proceeds from the sale go towards
setting aside a portion of the funds to
be used as a memorial or a scholarship
that develop that benefits the
developmental disability Community could
be one way of remembering these people
and restoring their Humanity I'm happy
you okay let me go before Olivia starts
up let me go through some other names is
Jenny Horgan here all right you will be
next after after Olivia thank you for
your
patience good evening Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Olivia paric and I'm from
bone New Hampshire I'm here today to
testify in strong support of the ad Rd
respit grant program at just 21 years
old I have lived the reality of
Alzheimer's caregiving when my
grandfather was diagnosed in 2021 my
family made the decision to move my
grandparents into our home uring that he
had the support he needed at first we
managed but soon it became impossible he
wandered outside forgetting which house
was ours he became confused anxious and
paranoid the Sund Downing was the worst
he grew angry aggressive and
unrecognizable to my grandmother who
could no longer sleep beside him we
installed cameras door sensors and took
shifts just to keep him safe caregiving
wasn't a responsibility it consumed Our
Lives even when we hired help we were
never truly off the clock but those few
hours of respit allowed us to keep up
with work school and our own health this
support is essential it prevents burnout
and allows families to keep loved ones
at home longer with dignity Alzheimer's
care isn't just emotionally exhausting
it's financially crippling and just two
months we spent $22,000 on home care and
that wasn't even 24/7 coverage when my
grandfather transitioned into Memory
Care the financial strain only grew
$67,000 for five months at one facility
that's $133,000 per month and $48,000
for four months at another at $122,000
per month families like mine will do
whatever it takes to care for our loved
ones but it comes at an unbearable cost
the funding the adrd respit grant
program provides barely scratches the
surface but it is still a
Lifeline this isn't just my family story
more than 11 million Americans provide
unpaid Alzheimer's care totaling 18
billion hours each year in New Hampshire
the state with the second oldest
population in the country the need for
support is only growing the financial
and emotional burden leads to
devastating burnout nearly 60% of
Alzheimer's caregivers report high
levels of stress anxiety and
depression these are families stretch
beyond their limits doing everything
they can but without the support they
truly need Alzheimer's caregiving is
Relentless no one should have to choose
between their loved ones care and
financial ruin I urge you to support it
because caregivers need care too thank
time okay
Jenny Horgan is next but before she
begins I want to do another roll call
espo Bonnie Dunham
Dunham you'll be after her you'll be
after Jenny thank you for your patience
Jenny thank you chairman wer and members
of the committee my name is Johnny Horan
I'm the senior public policy manager at
the Alzheimer's Association and as you
just heard from one of our our amazing
Advocates Olivia we are here to ask for
your support of the Alzheimer's and
other related dementia respit grant
program in New Hampshire there are an
estimated 20 more than 26,500
individuals living with Alzheimer's or
other dementia and an estimated 48,000
caregivers providing care to them
caregivers of those living with
Alzheimer's or dementia have incredibly
challenging jobs often assisting their
loved ones with one or more daily
activities of daily living including
bathing dressing eating as well as
multiple instrumental activities such as
paying bills shopping and
transportation more than 80% of the help
provided to older adults in the United
States comes from family members friends
or other unpaid caregivers and in 2024
alone as Olivia said that's over 77
million hours of unpaid care in order to
provide care to their loved one
caregivers of people with dementia are
more likely to report substantial
emotional financial and physical
difficulties than caregivers of people
Liv without dementia uh to further
reduce the burden on caregivers New
Hampshire has the Alzheimer's and other
related dementia reate grant program
which one received can assist a
caregiver in acquiring alternative
temporary care for their loved one so
that they can take a break while knowing
that their loved one is safely cared for
these Services can be VAR provided in a
variety of settings including the
individual's home assisted living
facilities and nursing homes this
temporary relief enables caregivers an
opportunity to manage and improve their
own health importantly the adrd respit
grant program can not only help redu
caregivers reduce burnouts but also
potentially allow an individual to delay
entering a more costly living situation
like a long-term care facility
ultimately saving granted Staters and
the state significant long-term care
costs it is vitally important than when
appropriate and if an individual so
chooses they are able to remain in their
home as long as possible preventing
caregiver burnout for those caring for
the loved one living with Alzheimer's or
dementia is instrument m al to ensuring
that choice exists that's why we're
asking for your support today for the
funding for the adrd rest bit grant
much okay before Bonnie gets up to
speak I call Bonnie
Dunham I'm I'm Lewis or Louie whatever
you I did call your name yes I got
excited and came right up sorry I've
been sitting here for a little bit say
your name again uh my name is Lewis
Esposito and behind me is Bonnie Dunham
Bonnie follows you yeah all right thank
you after Bonnie let me ask let me go
through some more
khabib he's
left uh
Elizabeth from 40 Rogers Avenue in
conquer it looks I can't quite make out
the last name I think it begins with an
H hat might be Hanigan or hat
here Meredith hat Hartfield
Hatfield all right I got you on the on
the on the list and your name again
Lewis espito ah okay Lewis all right and
after you is Kristen thank you go ahead
Lewis my name is Lewis ESP bazito and I
serve as the executive director of AEL
New Hampshire um I'm not going to repeat
I'm sure you all are really hungry um
all the testimony that you saw from
everyone wearing pink today um our
voices are loud and I hope you hear us
uh between direct support Workforce
housing and DD Services Medicaid is an
important part of all of our lives and I
hope you guys really heard that message
today so I'm not going to speak from
that perspective I'm also a former
special education teacher of many years
um you've heard plenty about education
funding and people's opinions about that
I agree with that um so um I'm not going
to get into specifics but I'm not going
to speak from that perspective I'm als
Al a parent of two young children um
we've struggled with with daycare bills
throughout our lives until we got
recently to uh kindergarten um I'm also
a father um and I'm not going to speak
from that perspective um I'm also a
family member of a brother who's on the
police force um I'm not going to speak
from the perspective of that either
because but I really feel that it's
important for um supporting retirement
rights but what I am here is a president
of Brooklyn New Hampshire and I just
want you to know that I'm I'm all I'm
very concerned about the the federal
government and how would this budget
affect if there were cuts from the
federal level if if this was to pass or
not to pass um with the further with the
cuts affect Medicaid further than you
all aware um cuts to education is that
is that taken into count to some of
these bills in your thought process um
and if this is a reality if pass how
would these Services look if this bill
is passed in the federal government
we're really nervous about that everyone
here is really nervous about that and
there something that no one has spoken
about this whole entire U evening so I
just want you all to um and please just
to um consider these very real threats
they're not they're not hypothetical
they're very real and we're very nervous
about what could come so um thank you
time okay kren Evans will be followed by
Bonnie
Dunham or's or have I got something out
here Bonnie was next all right I'm
Shuffling cards here too much and then
Kirsten I know you lost my place because
I was
declin so somehow
you my cards are getting scrambled as I
get through I don't understand it all
right so this is Bonnie followed by
Meredith Hatfield thank you um I'm
baronnie Dunham and I live in miramac
New Hampshire along with two of your
lovely committee members um
and I want to say as you consider this
budget please fully support funding for
people with disabilities and their
families you can do that by fully
funding the developmental Services
budget um Family centered early supports
and services Adult Services and other
critical funding programs as well as
sufficient funding to address the the
DSP shortage um in other essential needs
for families of people with
disabilities I'm the mom of a wonderful
44 year-old son who experiences he a
complex young guy um combination of
Developmental Disabilities he's also fun
determined and charming and he wants me
to make sure that you know that he's
worked at Wendy's for 24 years um he
pays taxes he's the only one I know
who's happy to do that and spend some of
his paycheck at local Town um Town shops
and
restaurants he needs full-time
one-on-one support um in order to be a
fully contributing and participating
member of the community and I sent you
some pictures to show what his life
looked like um he needs that level of
assistance right now he lives at home
with my husband and I um we're 247 car
takers and since his last DSP retired
and we have not been able to find a new
one because of insufficient funding for
dsps they can do better at at McDonald's
and Target um my husband and I were both
in our 70s are supporting him at Wendy's
four mornings a week before I go to my
actual real job um and in his community
based activities we need I funding so
dsps can make a living wage and we don't
have to keep doing this forever because
honestly we can't um my husband and
sorry my husband and I adore our son
he's he's really adorable um he's
wonderful he makes our life's joyful and
it's never dull um but without the
services we receive through gateways
including respit so that we can get an
occasional break we just can't continue
to support him in our home and in the
community and save the state just so
much money um by doing that Sean's
quality of life is not assured he's
dependent upon the supports that he
receives from us and the services he
receives through gateways and he's also
very very dependent on the budget that
you pass um and so please not only pass
a really responsible budget for people
with disabilities but make it so
responsible that no matter what happens
in Washington New Hampshire people with
disabilities are still protected thank
you
okay so we got Meredith Hatfield
next and she's here all right I'm going
to go through some more names see who's
here Brendan
Williams all right you'll be after
Meredith thank you thank you uh good
evening my name is Meredith Hatfield and
I'm with the nature conservancy in New
Hampshire thank you for your service
your patience uh and your attention
tonight it's been a humbling afternoon
I'm here to raise uh issues with two uh
proposals in house bill one and House
Bill two one has already been spoken to
so I'll be brief and that is the
proposed raid of the renewable energy
fund uh House Bill one proposes to
transfer $10 million from the rate payer
funded renewable energy fund to the
general fund we urge you to reject this
proposal to sweep dedicated funds and
shift them from their lawful intended
uses that benefit electric rate payers
from whom the funds were collected and
instead uh becomes an unlawful General
uh tax We Believe shifting these funds
is an improper use of dedicated rate
payer funds and instead we urge you to
direct the New Hampshire Department of
energy to actually spend those funds on
eligible New Hampshire local energy
projects as required by RSA 362
F10 I will be submitting written
testimony I'll go into more detail on
this
issue uh the second issue is uh the
permitting streamlining propos proposals
that are in uh house bill
2 we are uh concerned about some of uh
some aspects of these proposals and
again I will cover this in more detail
in written testimony but wanted to bring
them to your attention uh we understand
completely the goal of uh producing more
housing in New Hampshire particularly
housing that is Affordable and uh
available for our
Workforce however um these changes are
that are being proposed in the name of
making permitting environmental
permitting easier for housing uh
actually would apply to all development
and Dees analysis shows that H new
housing only makes up 30% of alteration
of terrain permits and only 10% of
wetlands permits so uh I just wanted to
note that uh what we would be doing is
changing and making uh permits easier
for a wide range uh of
development uh we are concerned about
proposed shifts of staff and duties from
the fish game department and the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources to Dees we deeply respect the
work of Dees but we are concerned that
this proposed streamlining that
consolidates the staff and duties would
be detrimental to the important services
that dncr is natural heritage Bureau and
Fish and Game provide to protect the
health the water resources and the
wildlife of New
Hampshire uh we would urge you to take
more time to review these complex
proposals including in front of the
policy Committees of the house uh
environment and agriculture resources
Recreation and development fish and game
and Marine Resources to name a few um we
do want to um thank Dees for all the
time they've spent with us explaining
these changes to us and also thank
Division 1 and Dees for supporting a
change in the effective date we think
this is critical if this goes into
effect if it moves forward on June 30
the staff can't possibly make this
happen effectively on July 1 and we
think it would actually slow down and
complicate permitting so we thank
Division 1 for that change and I will uh
make the rest of my comments and writing
you thank you Mr chairman and uh
honorable members of the committee good
evening uh my name is Brendan Williams
I'm the present CEO of the New Hampshire
healthc care Association uh we represent
a facility based long-term care uh
nursing homes Assisted Living uh
Continuing Care retirement communities
and uh also the Cedar Crest Center for
children with disabilities as you could
perhaps imagine our foremost priority in
this budget is to see that there be a
Medicaid rate increase uh for nursing
homes and also for the cedarest center
for kids um that really is um something
that would build upon the good work that
this uh body did uh in the current
budget uh when we look at the costs uh
that nursing homes have incurred uh for
example since the pandemic uh began uh
wage costs alone are up 36% for
nonsupervisory uh nursing home employees
and that's just since February of 2020
uh through January of this year and yet
our Workforce is 7% smaller uh than it
was uh in New Hampshire for nursing
homes uh before the pandemic began uh
despite these pay increases uh we just
can't find the work workers and it
doesn't help that every day uh roughly
1,200 registered nurses uh leave the
state of New Hampshire to work in
Massachusetts so uh whatever we can do
to keep Granite Staters here uh to serve
our aging population is obviously a
great investment and I also want to uh
tout uh choices for Independence this is
an interconnected system uh we rely upon
Home Care uh even though we represent a
facility based care because we discharge
a rehabilitated uh patients uh into the
Home Care setting uh my wife works in
home health she's had three clients uh
go into nursing homes uh the most recent
uh lived to uh the age of
96 uh before she went into a nursing
home and although she will not return uh
to her own home I think that's a tesate
to the success of choices for
Independence but the consequence to
nursing homes is is that people are
entering uh when they're sicker uh when
they're older uh we have one of the
nation's oldest nursing home populations
and when their resources are depleted
which is where you come in and uh I know
you'll do the compassionate thing uh
again in terms of providing a funding
increase uh not withstanding the
difficult uh state budget situation I
thank you very much for your public
service thank
you all right going through and list
Haley
Dunlap Jason Andrews right here all
right you're next after Jason is Marie
Morgan
here you you'll be following Jason thank
you
I've
um i' um good good afternoon my name is
Jason Andrews I'm from the mo
Center um the people on my team that
could be affected by these budget
changes
can are my home care providers and my
day staff I have been with my provider
since
2017 and my day staff in senide
2021 through the through the help of My
Career Team I was able
to join the rising stars per per group
for 10 years ago
and I stand be and I stand to you today
as I stand before you as the president
of rising
stars and my my peers have confidence in
me to be to be their
president our um regulations funding for
programs is a so important important to
me and my peers this money allows us to
go out into the community and public and
activities while making mean
meaningfulness com uh
[Music]
Community
um con
connections these programs help us help
people like me and others on the DDD
waivers can continue to be successful
communities thank you for your time and
for
you all right Marie Morgan is next let
me go through some more names and see
who's
Hampshire Jeremiah getlan or
giy Jeremiah is he
here all right you'll be
okay good afternoon chairman wer uh
finance committee members I realize it's
been a long afternoon and I'll try to be
brief brief uh my name as you mention is
Marie Morgan I'm from Goffstown New
Hampshire I agree with the testimony
presented by these previous speakers
regarding proposed cuts to so many
programs impacting New Hampshire
residents I stand before you today
because I have a
question regarding House Bill two and
Constitution it's my understanding
that house bill two is a budget bill
which is why it's in front of you as
finance committee
members yet under part two of the New
1984 it says that no section or footnote
of any budget bill
shall contain any
provision which
establishes
amends or
repeals statuary
law other than
Provisions
establishing amending or
repealing operating and capital expenses
for the executive legislative and
judicial branches of government
let me read it
again no section or footnote of any
budget Bill shall contain any provision
which establishes amends or repeals
statutory law other than Provisions
establishing amending or repealing those
operating in capital expenses for the
executive leg legislative and judicial
branches
so my question is
this if the New Hampshire
Constitution says budget bills shall not
do all that why does House Bill two do
it this refers to House Bill
one when it says budget bills House Bill
two is not considered a budget Bill why
not it is the enabling legislation for
the budget Bill well it says is any
budget bill so how is that defined any
budget bill because hb1 is budget bill
hb2 is enabling hp1 okay so here here's
some examples from House Bill 2 line one
for example it says RSA 597 section 2
regarding bail and release of defendants
is
repealed and reenacted
Etc then line two says RSA 212 section A
talks about fishing game and endangered
species is
amended then we go on to line 19
requires school boards to adopt student
cell phone policies another one defines
the eligible student for the purposes of
enrollment in EFA accounts another one
expands the types of purposes for which
educational trust funds may be used
another authorizes the State Board of
Education to modify determinations of
Education adequacy grants in line
79 suspends Revenue sharing with towns
under that's been in there since I think
2013 it's a different program that's
referred to in that RSA that we haven't
used that to share we still do several
sharing um places in the budget but not
that particular one and that's that's
something we should probably just delete
it because we haven't we haven't shared
along with that RSA for I don't know 12
years or so so I guess the bottom line
is is this house bill to a budget
let's see was that was Marie right yes
it all right so next do we have Jeremy
is going to speak let me go through some
let me go through some names Jeremy
before you speak is Jackie Cowell here
all right you're next after Jeremy thank
you for your
patience uh hi my name is Jeremiah githu
and I'm here to speak an opposition of
hb1 and The Cutting of the UNH budget I
am a current sophomore at PL State
University a proud cellular molecular
biology major and the Hub coordinator
for New Hampshire youth movement at PSU
as was discussed by my peers uh Pou
State un pouth State and the New
Hampshire University system as a whole
has been going through hard times
because diminish funding and low
attendance I have talked to students who
including myself have faced the
consequences of this diminished funding
for their Department programs that were
once established disappearing and as of
recent a propos cut to the amities
Department getting 2third of the current
faculty and the consequence of this
change killing Plymouth State From the
Inside Out interviewing students I have
seen the passion that we have for our
campus the beautiful White Mountains the
wonderful facility who work day and
night to support us and the wonderful
Community made up of people from all
around the area but one thing is in
common Plymouth State University is
dying and it has been New Hampshire is
dead last in public university funding
and has the highest instate tuition
rates to balance that out putting the
institution on the back students we are
$77,000 below the medium rage for per
student funding let me be frank a 16.5
million decrease over the next two years
for the UNH system would kill our public
universities that have been a resource
for New Hampshire students to get
cheaper public education since 1866 in
the case of unh 187
1817 in the case of Plum State
University in 1909 for Keen state with
this less and less of our high school
students will be staying in state for
education or work leaving yes less of
the younger generation in New Hampshire
our universities are in danger and this
will effectively be the final nail in
the coffin for UNH school systems thank
you all right thank you Jeremy before we
go on to Jackie I want to read a few
more
names is
um Cyrus anger bodic here yes I am all
right you will you will be next thank
you good evening how do you do I'm
Jackie Cowell from Early Learning New
Hampshire we're a Statewide nonprofit
Katie had mentioned it before um and
we're here to talk with you about child
care and I'm really appreciative of
being able to talk to the whole
committee I had the chance to talk to
division three uh last week so um I've
had a few childcare providers were
hoping to come today they couldn't they
had some letters I think they've they've
uploaded them online so but I did want
to read one of them to you um from
alphabets in Manchester they have two
programs and so Muriel Allard founded it
40 years ago her niece uh Nicole Allard
Nutter uh runs it now and so she shared
this and I want to share this with you
she said they have a licensed capacity
of 323 at one childcare program 264 at
the other they have ample space for more
children one of the programs could take
70 more kids and uh the other one can
take 130 and the only reason they're not
full is the Staffing shortage and so
their number one priority is restoring
that 15 million in child care Workforce
grants and um and she mentions also that
it was very successful for them when it
came out in August last year of
2024 uh it helped them you you'll see in
her letter it helped them keep those
credential staff the ones who were
really terrific at their jobs they
stayed and so she she's really they're
really hoping this continues just a
quick story is that in
2023 these $15 million and Workforce
grants went out the door it was very
much a strong bipartisan vote to do this
they were General funds in
2023 and um it was very important that
again the strong bipartisan vote in hb2
as well they did mention um and direct
that uh DHHS put that 15 million in this
next by Anum coming up and they did as
you'll see on page
881 it is zeroed out in the governor's
proposal however we do believe and we'd
love to work with you we do believe
there's funding available right now that
can be used that's an allowable use for
these childcare Workforce grants that
would not require General funds so I
hope to work with you to restore it
thank you thank you all
right Cyrus is next and then state
representative Chris
you thank you all so much for still
being here given the hour um my name is
Cyrus anger bich I am a student at
Plymouth State University and I'm here
representing myself as a citizen and a
voter in New Hampshire I live in
Plymouth and I love my town uh and I am
deeply deeply concerned not just about
the university but about the town itself
given the potential Cuts uh to the usn
to
usnh uh while a lot of what I'm going to
say is applicable to usnh as a whole
given my own uh time at Plymouth state
which is where I currently am uh I will
primarily be referring to that I mostly
Echo a lot of sentiments that fellow
students of mine have brought up
especially things brought up by Jeremiah
and Ethan as you heard earlier um
Plymouth state is kind of a life uh
Lifeline directly to the north for a lot
of economic
uh the actual when school is in session
the town of plymouth's size almost
doubles so businesses in town rely
heavily on students being able to
regularly come I personally know someone
who was working at a business that had
to go from being open every day of the
week to shutting down some days of the
week because during offseasons they
could not uh maintain opening costs um a
couple other things I want to bring up
is the fact that uh with the cuts
already having happened uh it's not like
Plymouth state has some Grand budget
that they're able to work with over the
past few years they've already cut over
a hundred staff and they've done every
single thing that they can to as little
as possible change the student
experience and therefore as little as
possible uh prevent people from coming
it's coming now to the point where many
people I've personally spoken to have
wanted to transfer take their money go
somewhere else most people I've spoken
to are planning to go to schools in
Massachusetts um many people that I've
interacted with have have uh come from
Massachusetts and back to New Hampshire
and come here to Plymouth and have loved
the school but have expressed that part
of them kind of regrets it given what
the funding cuts that are happening now
um the way that the school is designed
is focused on Innovation it's focused on
letting uh students look at you know a
broad range of important perspectives
from engineering to business to
entrepreneurship when it comes to uh
bringing Innovation into New Hampshire
bringing economic GS into New Hampshire
and a cut like this to the schools as
they are right now given that again we
are the lowest school we are the lowest
state in the nation when it comes to uh
paying for public education and even if
we raised it by $1,000 per student at
Plymouth State we would still be 50th
and we would not have to worry about
these uh cuts and we would still be able
to keep most of our faculty all of that
being said I truly implore you not for
the sake of me as a student but for the
sake of me a resident of Plymouth and
for the sake of all of the people that I
know that are from further north and
rely heavily on the uh economic input
that having the university system in
place as it is to not execute it to not
choke the lifeblood out of the north of
listening thank you all right before I
before representative one more all right
representative Schulz I've got a few
others here I think I read
Walford Caitlyn
berer ah okay you'll be after
barter okay all right so we got two more
out after representative Schulz
representative Schulz thank you Mr chair
it would have been fun to be the very
last speaker but I will be brief because
I know you guys have had a very long day
my message is simple um you've probably
heard a lot of stories about the most
vulnerable in New Hampshire and I think
that that should be given the very first
part of your priority when you look at
the budget I would say this category
list includes children mothers in need
of help with child care mothers in
general probably
seniors people who are ill people with
disabilities public school students
people in poverty people earning low
wages I will remind you that we default
to the federal minimum wage is $725
cents and you think well not many people
make minimum wage in New Hampshire um
about
130,000 graned Staters earn less than
$15 an hour that is a vulnerable wage
I would include um people with medical
debt and student
debt and I would also add I'm a um a
city councelor here in conquer and the
one thing that I also know you've heard
today is that we we should stop the
downshifting of costs to uh cities and
towns to all but the most 12 most
prosperous cities and towns in New
Hampshire that's like almost all of New
Hampshire would benefit from that so my
message is simple please keep the most
vulnerable at the top of your agenda and
stop the down uh shifting of costs to
our uh all but the 14 or so most
prosperous cities in towns and thank you
for listening to so many people today I
berer sorry you had to wait so long
that's okay and you did it on purpose so
I could be last I get it um first thank
you guys for being here for the whole
Sun all the way up to all the way down
very much appreciate it um so good
evening honorable chairman and valued
members of the finance committee thank
you for taking the time to listen to My
Testimony my name is Caitlyn Bernier and
I'm in opposition of this budget I live
in marac where I'm a member of our
school budget committee Planning and
Building committee and a mother of two
very pre-teen children who you who one
of utilizes special education and I am
on a fixed income I am speaking to you
today as all of those things and many
more active roles that I play in my
community as a budget Committee Member I
have been in your position Al Bet on a
much smaller scale but I learned a lot
from our public hearings about my
community's needs and struggles I also
learned a lot about our District budget
expenses and revenue which we don't have
much of and actually receive much less
than I had anticipated since we are the
eighth largest District in New Hampshire
the state has routinely reduced the
amount of special education funding
provided to our district despite
inflation and is currently adding more
barriers to Grants and funding the cost
of funding and adequate education is not
being met by the state which in turn
puts the cost burden on our taxpayers in
the form of higher property taxes the
consistent concern with the increase in
property taxes is prevalent throughout
our community and our state as you have
all heard today yet we still see these
non-stop bills to expand our efas your
obligation is to the m the majority of
children in New Hampshire that utilize
public education first and foremost the
state meaning you all need to look at
other Avenue Vues for Revenue to
adequately fund public education so
seniors and those on fixed incomes
aren't taxed out of their homes I grew
up in the town I am now choosing to
raise my own children in a town where we
look out for our neighbors and work
together to improve our community and
solve our problems my ask today is that
you consider your neighbors especially
children and seniors and your obligation
to adequately fund a prop Education
Without more burden on property taxes
for your constituents and I thank you
very much again for your time thank you
thank
you is there anyone else present who did
not get a chance to
testify who came here to
testify I am grateful to the members of
the finance committee for the almost
five hours that you have listened to the
public it's uh almost a record and it's
a very long thing and representative
Maguire might want to make a further
announcement yeah I think we should make
representative people's an honorary
member of this committee because he was
here the whole day long
Jonah 98 so we had 98 people that
testified about another 25 26 names that
I called that had had to leave so so
we've heard from a lot of the
public uh a lot of it was the same
subject but I hope you've all written
down what you needed to know and what
you plan to work on I thank the
committee and you remember that
represent McGuire provided some